the democratic administration of
illinois the governorship
funneled federal coveted relief funds to
a local black lives matter organization
under the guise of crime prevention
and one of the organized one of the
leaders of this local blm group has
actually been charged with violent
crimes themselves
so it just i mean just outright this is
this is crazy to hear the democrats put
in place policies in chicago in new york
and in la that result in crime they
support riots they support it black
lives matter rioters
then once all this chaos and insanity
happens the federal government comes out
the democrats and they say we're going
to give federal coveted relief funds
your tax dollars by the way
and then they shuffle it right back into
blm groups but it's not just this store
there's a huge scandal ongoing where
apparently blm we don't even know where
their fundraising is going no one knows
is in charge their address is apparently
not even real and it's gotten so bad
that even blue states are threatening
the blm organization over their lack of
financial transparency and blm has now
shut down fundraising outright so we got
to get into all that stuff plus we got
more developments in the
i gotta admit rather tired ongoing
spotify joe rogan controversy
controversy but the white house has
chimed in jon stewart has chimed in and
i kid you not the president of brazil
is chiming in
if you were going to tell me that joe
rogan's show would end up being involved
in an international incident i'd be like
i don't know about all that but here we
go we're getting to that point i
wouldn't be surprised if like vladimir
putin comes out and he's like i like
joel rogan and then joe biden is like we
cannot have this kind of support for for
misinformation and that starts the whole
ukraine russia war whatever
but we'll get in all that stuff we got
joe biden coming out once again lying
saying you can't buy cannons he was like
the second amendment doesn't allow you
when when they rid it you could wrote it
you couldn't buy cannons
yo you can literally buy a cannon right
now like we pulled up the website
like it's we don't want anyone to buy
cannons obviously but it's like not hard
to find it's you're right james madison
literally wrote a letter to a private
ship owner telling him he could own
cannons
was that tucker carlson
james madison
joe biden wants to think you shouldn't
have a candidate you should actually
we're going to talk about all this and i
have to say first and uh all right
we were going to have dan crenshaw
tonight but he has to be in congress for
a vote and so you know with respect i'm
glad he's there and doing his job
because a lot of people in congress
don't so
unfortunately it just means he couldn't
be here luke came down because he wanted
to make sure he was a part of that show
but we have luke here instead so you can
all be uh what what uh happy grateful
yeah that's uh dan could make it cause
you get you get luke now first of all
tim we need to buy that cannon
immediately second of all hunk hunk
mother truckers welcome back beautiful
and amazing human beings freedom is
winning the official narrative along
with cnn is crumbling and we have the
unveiling of some of the biggest lies in
our society it's an amazing time to be
alive and uh thank you so much for
having me back i was looking forward to
a spirited conversation with mr crenshaw
sadly that doesn't happen we have
sheamus though so
i know
i was bummed too yeah but yeah
anyway if you want to
if you want to support me you can on the
best political one
excuse me there sir irishman
you can support me
the best political shirts.com and you
can get uh spirited t-shirts like the
one that i have right now that say the
real island boys which you could
exclusively get on the best political
shirts.com and i'm also going to be
doing a meetup in florida uh in fort
lauderdale you want to be a part of that
sign up on my email list on we are
change.org and uh
here's uh
spirited oh wow spirited is a word for
it
make fun of his glasses no you know what
actually i think the glasses are the one
thing about him that make him seem smart
so i won't knock him for that it's great
to have luke here no i actually am happy
to do a show with him believe it or not
despite the fact that he's constantly
insulting me in chat just for keeping
his seat warm true my name is sheamus
coughlin i am a cartoonist
did i interrupt you can i interrupt you
i'm just i'm just clearing my voice here
i'm sorry yeah i gotta cover my mind
it'd be a shame if that went out huh
so i have a political cartoon channel
called freedom tunes we just released a
cartoon about justin trudeau and the
truckers if you guys want to check that
out it seems to be very popular right
now the fans are enjoying it i think
you will too and man there's a whole lot
i want to get into tonight with the the
stories you brought up i'm excited about
it so much man there's a lot
of masks scientists say you got to put
pantyhose over your face it's messed up
hopefully luke lets me get a word in
edgewise
oh hi ian crossland over here what's up
everybody uh ian crossland.net also very
happy to be here luke great to see you
my man
maybe we could toss it over to our fifth
guest before uh
yeah we brought it up or fouchy or
somebody i redecorated just a little bit
luke brought a guest luke insisted this
is the best part listen luke insisted we
get a bunch of florida oranges but the
funniest thing is the big box in the
middle is mango oh yeah it's like
they're like i don't know orange box
okay come on
that's partly linda's fault yeah but as
a florida man and a polish florida man
we are very gracious we brought a lot of
oranges for everyone to consume here
straight from florida yeah of course
like everything is about ethnicity with
you i don't know anyway
i'm also here yeah i am pushing buns in
the corner i did buy the mango drinks
they're delicious the box was orange i
don't care that they're not actually
oranges they also have caffeine in them
and i'm not sorry sorry before we get
started ladies and gentlemen head over
to timcast.com become a member help
support our work we are principally
funded by your membership the website
runs off of membership for the most part
and as a member you'll get access to
exclusive members only podcasts from
this show the uncensored edition we put
up a show every monday through thursday
around 11 p.m so there will be one
tonight but also if you go to
timcast.com click the store you can get
your very own that's that's not the
right one there we go your very own free
hunk hunk t-shirt this free honk honk
t-shirt is got the canadian maple leaf
but it's modeled after the free hong
kong flag and it's a free hong kong so
if you want to help spread the word on
the great honkening and simultaneously
support our show check out
thetimcast.com store it's also uh it's
pinned to the chat over in our in our
live stream and don't forget to smash
the like button subscribe to this
channel one like is one honk man and i i
just want to say
i've seen all these videos that have
been ongoing from the great honking
protest seeing these truckers out there
just want to make sure you guys realize
that the people out here who are in
these trucks when they're not near near
their homes they've traveled very far
they need food they need help they got
to find the bathroom i'm not going to
presume to speak for them as to what
they do need but i certainly think it's
feasible you know it's reasonable to say
they're going to need your your local
support especially when the city is
threatening to bring in police they want
to bring in military so you know shout
out to all those people that are
standing up for freedom but let's get
into that first big story we got from
timcast.com illinois governor gave 300
dollars of federal relief funding to
black lives matter this is
three hundred thousand dollars in
federal covet 19 relief funds went to
the lake county chapter of blm
i could not when i saw this you know
what i wanted to do i went on twitter
and i was like what do i tweet and i was
like oh i know i'll tweet are you paying
attention wait oh my god no i can't
tweet that for not only does jackpot
tweet that for everything i'm like i
think he just we're paying attention now
especially if you're following that
twitter so i just said i'm not even
gonna ask i know you're paying attention
it's this bad let me pull up their
official documentation this is covid19
relief funds check it out your business
was shut down you're in massive debt
you're getting evicted from your house
your business was burned down in a riot
so money was taken from your tax dollars
or printed and borrowed and the
democratic administration from the
federal government gives it to the
states
and then illinois says we're going to
give it right back to blm here it is
right here look at this under the guise
of criminal ju of criminal justice and
crime intervention black lives matter
got 300 000
when we talk about january 6 when we
talk talk about the federal government
going after only one political faction
letting the riders do whatever they want
barely prosecuting anybody going after a
bunch of magamimas who were let in the
capital and then you can see they're
directly funding them
you know what maybe the reason not going
to charge any of these riders with
terrorism because then they'd all
basically be committing some kind of
sedition and insurrection and then they
would be ineligible so when when they
when they sued madison medicine cothor
and saying he couldn't run for
re-election i tweeted out kamala harris
is ineligible to run for public office
because she engaged in insurrection
against these united states by providing
material support to those engaged in
insurrection and terror against this
country amen so blm is kind of the
perfect scam here because there are
absolutely no results needed what are
the strings attached to when you give
them money what are they going to say
it's part of what's brilliant about this
kind of political activism generally
speaking the worse the problem gets the
more they can claim that they're needed
and the more they can claim that you
have to give them money or else you
don't care about the problem on top of
that when it comes to jb i'm not sure if
y'all are familiar with him or if the
audience knows much about him but being
from the state of illinois originally i
can give you a few facts on him that
will uh leave you unsurprised with the
fact that he would mismanage federal
funds in this way
firstly he is every single thing that
the left claims to hate and he's all of
them at the same time it's almost
amazing he is a billionaire trust fund
baby venture capitalist and in the state
of illinois he raised the collective tax
burden by 5.25 billion dollars still
couldn't balance the budget he tried to
raise it eight billion but wasn't able
to but he himself does everything he can
to avoid taxes he had a second house
which was a mansion and he had every
single toilet removed from it so it
would be considered uninhabitable when
the tax assessor came and he wouldn't
have yes and so he wouldn't have to pay
as much in taxes he's an absolute swamp
creature so so so we could take the
toilets out of here and just put like we
could dig a hole in the backyard and i
don't got to pay taxes yes well you have
to pay some taxes but it's assessed of
as being at a lower value if it's
uninhabited or uninhabitable wow yes
that's that's amazing very slimy well if
there's anything that the government's
really good at it's wasting your money
and scamming people and this is a
perfect example of this where did that
money go to an organization that can't
even account for 60 million dollars as
of course there's ongoing investigations
into blm right now i mean what did you
expect and then i mean there's there's
so many different consequences here
there's so many different ramifications
here there's so many different ways we
could even talk about this specific
story but this is how the government
chooses to to to take your money that
you they save them they create the
problem exactly then they take your
money to fix the problem and give it
back to the people creating the problem
or partly and then make more problems
right right
so uh the president of the lake county
blm chapter clyde
mclemore was arrested in kenosha in 2021
and charged with felony battery of a
police officer so look
you got somebody
who
is actually arrested for a violent crime
being given money under the guise of
preventing violent crimes in chicago now
innocent until proven guilty of course
always and with a lot of the stuff going
on these past few years i'm not
necessarily going to just blindly trust
cops or anything like that but yo
blm
this is not the first scandal it'll
certainly not be be the last scandal
i i think
what people need to understand i don't
know how to say it
there is a powerful element of the
government that hates you that is
actively funding people who have
destroyed lives and are destroying your
businesses and your homes and we're
watching them do it with your own
dollars yeah exactly they funded an
organization that called for the
disbanding of the family unit they
called they funded an organization that
literally has marxist talking points
that that wants to of course spread
divide and conquer techniques that have
been effectively deployed in the united
states and have worsened race relations
here in this country yeah well it's
funny because i was going to ask the
question could you imagine any
right-wing organizations receiving this
kind of money from the federal
government like the patriot prayer group
but then i realized they're pretty much
entirely employed by the federal
government aren't they yeah patriot
prayer patriot prayer group i'm sorry
what's the organization okay
i'm sorry yeah i don't know about i
don't know what's going on with patriot
prayer guys but uh oath keepers
apparently yeah yeah man
we were talking about this the other day
with julie kelly where you have all of a
sudden these these people everyone's
asking like why aren't they being
charged in the january 6 you know riot
and then all of a sudden they get
charged because they were going to be
called as witnesses and now they can
plead the fifth
yeah dude very sketchy i just
i i got to be honest though i don't want
to be debbie downer i don't want to be
negative nancy right for some reason we
have these alliterative words
you know depressive but uh
i really do think that we're seeing
these stories
it's exposing what's going on and it
used to be that this stuff happened and
we didn't even know it was happening
around us so the what you got to watch
out for is you know because i felt i
fall victim to this sometimes as well
you read all of this really bad stuff
and you're like man things must be
really bad and then i stop and i'm like
actually we wouldn't even know this was
happening 10 years ago exactly so it's
actually
you know it's bad it happened
but we've got investigative reporters
exposing all of this stuff that's pretty
good yeah there's a theory out there is
you know people are asking themselves is
the world becoming a worser place or are
we just finding out exactly how the
world really works and i think we're
finding out exactly how the world really
works and there's consequences for
negative actions uh for every action
there's an equal reaction that's new in
third law and even just you know
yesterday we had the indiana attorney
general come out and say that blm is a
scam and he said that the house of cards
is starting to fall as of course there's
major questions about the 60 million
dollars that were given to them by major
institutions by very powerful players
and now even governments not just
multinational corporations pushing an
agenda not just blackrock and the esg
social credit score but but there's so
much influence here when it comes to
pushing this narrative and the
unraveling of it it's going to have
equal consequences in my opinion there's
something interesting to be said about
individuals choosing to donate but the
the government funding i have to wonder
if you know i'm willing to bet illinois
is not the only state that did this
absolutely not i'd love to know to the
extent to which you've got these smaller
groups just think about this
we had riots all over the country it was
not centrally organized not necessarily
it may be through perhaps the democratic
party and like groups like act blue that
were bailing out a lot of these people
but the funding that went to these
smaller groups
in all these different places
where did where did they get that money
from if illinois was giving it to a
local chapter wouldn't would you know is
his government funding them in other
areas i'd have to assume yes and most
importantly what did they do with that
money is the bigger question asked here
and there it could be reasonable to to
ponder that maybe they don't want to
release the records of the 60 million
dollars because now the california and
the washington attorney general are
demanding the financial disclosures of
where their money came from you could
argue that maybe there's even more
governments that were involved here with
the funding of blm that they don't want
publicly released and that's why the
data hasn't been out there do you
remember that there was that guy in
california who had his own group called
black lives matter and he raised like
300 grand on his own and then they went
after him and tried like they destroyed
his life
he owned it before they did and they
went after him so this was an actual
activist this one's some guy trying but
it was like i repeat myself right but
was was this actually someone who
believed in the cause trying to raise
money or was he so when when blm first
started there was no like centralized
organization or anything so he was like
okay i'll make a non-profit we'll call
it this and his and he's he said his
goal was to bring the community and the
police together
so that we can end you know this clash
in this conflict right that flies in the
face of what they're actually trying to
do they're trying to abolish the police
so they accused him of being a charlatan
a fraud his fundraiser fundraising was
all suspended they went after his
finances and he was legitimate he was
like as far as i know he was totally
legitimate well that's the thing they
always go say black lives matter as if
that's all they actually want but they
know if you say blm what you're actually
saying is i support this organization
and the reason we know this is because
this guy was literally saying in the
most direct way possible black lives
matter and they said nope can't do that
it's it's time we recognize
this idea of the working class and the
elites and these other classes based on
100 years ago these writings of you know
100 year old dates is wrong or at least
needs to be updated because how do you
explain these urban unemployed leftists
who are not working class but they claim
to be and they hold these insane
ideologies and they support these insane
cultural ideologies they're not the
truckers are the working class
these people aren't you know i refer to
them somewhat as the intelligentsix or
college educated but they're not the
intelligentsia they're not smart people
no they're not they're not writing books
and they're not writing poems and
they're not saying i challenge the
they're just walking around going like
tell me whatever to do walmart they're
like the corp the corporate the
corporate npc class yeah they're
repeating statements instead of creating
art instead of creating entertainment
instead of actually building stuff
they're literally just saying just tell
me what to say and i'll say it tell me
what i need to do to to go along and get
this perfect
governmental environmental social credit
score that's going to of course profit
my business and at the end it's not a
stretch to imagine that more governments
supported blm financially because they
supported them in many different ways
whether it's george soros appointing a
whole bunch of attorney generals that
implemented a lot of their policies
whether it's government officials
bailing them out whether it's government
officials literally supporting them
giving them permits to march whether
it's dr fauci and bill de blasio
excusing their mass marches and
mobilization saying that they're good
for the general public and rather than
of course attack anyone who was going
against protest against the state that
was bad and that was causing sickness
and kovit to spread again there was so
much hypocrisy the state
coddled this movement and brought it to
a very significant place in our culture
that has had horrible effects on
everyone well let's let's pull up the uh
the bigger story in this in this whole
whole thing uh shout out to andrew kerr
of the washington examiner investigating
this black lives matter has shut down
fundraising days after liberal states
threatened legal action
we don't know who's in charge
we don't know where the money is
apparently they went to the address that
blm files and there's nothing there and
the people there are like i have no idea
what you're talking about there's no blm
here yo it's almost like
blm is a shadow organization that never
really existed so what is it is it a
charity blm well it's like wait are
there so the people who are encouraging
american citizens to burn down their
communities are sketchy this is crazy
yes yes
so if they start a charity black lives
matter i imagine it's a 501c3 i'm trying
to figure it out i think it says it is
and then what happened all these
chapters started spawning well there's
black lives matter there's local
chapters because anybody can make a
local whatever they want and they're not
charities but they probably are so they
might be charities too yeah but it's the
the black lives matter global network
foundation that's like the official
organization yo you've got california
saying like where's the money and they
went uh indiana says it's a scam the
indiana ag was like it's he's like it's
it's indicative of what scams do i'm
looking at it's a house of cards there's
the black lives matter foundation which
is not the black lives matter movement
it's also a foundation a 501 501c3
december 19th was formed and it's been
taking donations there's an advisory
from buzzfeed nbc is like watch out for
the black lives matter foundation
because it's not affiliated with the
movement uh so there you're starting to
see like money grab
fraudulent scams pop up at least in this
instance yeah so this is it right here i
pulled it up the black lives matter
global network foundation former
executive director was patrice cullors
everybody knows sir because she's that
lady bought all those houses right yeah
three i think three or four houses she
had five oh wow yeah she had five and
they were they were you know they were
they were up there huh and it's a 501c3
and currently it has non-profit
compliance issues
wow yeah well they're not disclosing the
finances they're not disclosing the
numbers they're supposed to have public
records of what is happening with that
money they're preventing people from see
it and and and when journalists are
asking about this the people who are
initially asked about this are now
trying to conceal their information or
hide who they are to not even be held
accountable for this as the california
department of justice is literally
threatening these leaders saying that
they could be held personally liable if
they don't disclose the financial record
let me just read this let me just read
this for you guys all right you you guys
ready for this one let me build a little
bit of suspense from influencewatch.org
purchase of former communist party of
canada headquarters
in july 2021 the non-profit m4bj
purchased a 10 000 square foot mansion
in downtown toronto did they take the
toilets out formerly served as the
headquarters of the communist party of
canada according to the washington
examiner the bulk of the 8.1 million
purchase price came via a restricted
capital grant provided by the blm global
network foundation where'd your money go
they took over the communist party
headquarters in toronto well this is
what i find so hilarious tim earlier you
were talking about the intelligentsia
and it is true according to pew research
that people who have higher education or
have been through higher education are
more likely to support blm but one thing
i find very interesting about that is if
this is a movement which is more likely
to be supported by really intelligent
people how did none of them figure out
that it was such a scam
it's very funny because in this country
probably over the past hundred maybe 150
years our notion of what education is
supposed to be changed so in the past it
was something that was set aside for a
very small minority of people who could
handle things like learning greek and
latin by the time they were 16 years old
and who would be completely familiar
with the entire western lexicon and then
would go on to higher learning
now i think it's great that we have
widespread literacy and we've increased
access to education but when it comes to
higher education we've just tried to
funnel everyone through it even though
the entire model that was created
initially was for the particularly and
really highly intelligent and so what's
happened is we've dumbed down higher
education to the point where the people
who go through it can't even spot that
something like this is an unbelievably
obvious scam it's not that they can't
spot it it's that even just basic
questioning of the institution and the
organization labeled you a racist
labeled you as someone who was
intolerant labeled you as someone who
was bigoted when when you didn't support
these marxist ideas you were of course
attacked viciously by a lot of powerful
organizations and institutions that were
just blindly writing checks to these
organizations so that had a huge social
factor to it yeah no but and i would
even question the validity of that study
myself personally yeah so i i think it's
it's both i mean you're absolutely right
that they're not allowed to question it
but i think part of the reason they're
not allowed to question is because
higher education no longer has the same
message it used to which is that we
should be questioning things we should
be trying to discover new ideas and this
should be reserved for very intelligent
people who are actually capable of
wrestling with ideas and aren't just
going to go along with the group you
guys so that the whole whoopi goldberg
thing was started over the
mouse book and kill a mockingbird
getting removed from the curriculum the
new york post even claimed mouse was
banned it's literally not true so i've
got a couple points to make this is fun
so i was on facebook and this lefty guy
i know he like posted hey look they
banned mouse and then linked to a story
and i responded with they didn't ban it
they just took it off the curriculum and
the response was that means the school
banned it no and then i responded with
the gulag archipelago was also banned
and they all went whoa really and i was
like that's right
because it's not in their curriculum
that means it's banned isn't it yeah so
i saw another post right and it's all
it's this meme going around many of you
may have seen it where it's a stack of
books and all of these banned books and
it's from like occupy democrats or
something and it says kids listen if
anyone tells you that you don't that you
you can't read a book you need to find
this book and read it and decide for
yourself my response was absolutely we
should be sending kids the book rigged
by molly hemingway yeah so they can
learn about the election and if anyone
tells them they shouldn't read it that's
proof they should irreversible harm and
then it's actually funny because i saw
that post i saw that meme and one of the
books in the meme was like the joy of
sex and it's like yeah before a certain
age you probably shouldn't be reading
that but they're not banned books it's
no i know so so they told me you know
these these books aren't
these books are banned and i was like
when i was a kid a banned book meant if
you brought to school they'd take it
from you and call your parents
they'd be like this is inappropriate for
kids you should not be showing this and
usually it was like serious adult stuff
that's a banned book when they're just
like we're not going to make it required
reading but we don't care if you have it
in the library if you want to read it
but this is not banned no but this is uh
how did we how did we get into the book
thing again i don't know your well we
were just talking about higher education
and how
totally failed
is that being intelligent and educated
doesn't mean that you're moral
a lot of really intelligent people do
really immoral things like the nazis
scientists for instance but maybe blm as
well i don't know well i would consider
it i agree completely but i also think
that's a product of the fact that in
some ways we've reclassified what it
means to be intelligent so historically
and i think if you look at like aquinas
or aristotle their definition of
intelligence was that you were able to
see the world for what it was and then
act in accordance with it and now we've
changed it to more or less refer to
people who have something approximating
g which is what we usually talk about
when we're talking about iq like their
their ability to wrestle with
abstractions uh and notice patterns
their working memory that kind of thing
and those are all really important and
they're strongly correlated with with
economic success
but
intelligence in the classical sense also
does include a person's ability to
behave virtuously because virtue is just
acting within reasons rather than
choosing short-term pleasure which is
more intelligent i want to think of it
like that that bell curve meme of the
really dumb person yeah the mid midwit
and then like the smart person
and it's like the really really dumb
person understands you know that
many of them not all of them there's a
dunning-kruger effect but they're like
you know in
when you're smart you can make things
work and you can figure it out they're
really really smart people understand
this but the people in the middle are
like i went to school therefore i'm
smart exactly that their whole the whole
basis is
we're we're the better man because those
truckers never graduated college exactly
the non-college educated you know it's
really funny when the left mocks the
non-college educated working class
people
because they do dumb things i'm like the
funny thing is
those truckers those trades men and
women the people working for the fire
department for the police department
other organizations have experienced the
real world to a to a substantially
larger degree than college kids and they
make their decisions and actions based
off real life and these college
graduates have never actually
experienced real life and they live in a
bubble where they think they're smarter
than everybody but could not make they
they would never be able to figure out
how to make a rudimentary machine they'd
just be like i don't know the government
should do it for me and shame it's just
the system the education system rewards
people who are indoctrinated
successfully and are able just to
regurgitate and repeat the talking
points that are told to them and this is
why walmart goldman sachs the cia all of
them were singing the praises of blm and
their virtues and their marxist ideas
they were like this is a great idea the
cia even went on a tirade promoting
black panther as some kind of woke
ideology which is absolutely crazy and
mind-boggling so so these are
regurgitators and repeaters
and i would even question that kind of
mark of intelligence myself no i would
agree with you completely i mean so the
average college uh graduate has an iq of
about 114 so that's i mean that's a bit
above average but that's by no means
exceptional so to boast i graduated
colleges if that's any kind of
accomplishment anymore is absolutely
ridiculous and to look down on your
average working person who's like likely
just as smart as you and certainly has
more knowledge of the world than you do
is completely ridiculous i feel ashamed
that i went to college i feel changed
that i went into
i'm actually very i was privileged to be
able to go on i'm very glad that i was
able to go but it's true like to brag
about it to like look down on people
because you have a college degree and
they don't is absurd because basically
anyone can get a college degree nowadays
i still can't spend it's absurd i still
can't write and spell and i have a
college diploma it's like you don't have
to be smart you know to graduate college
you don't want to fill up fill out the
dotted line and hand in the paper 150
and just repeat what the professor tells
you to repeat here's what here's what i
i just find
i find it kind of sad because i really
want to help people succeed like when
people come to me and they ask me for
real advice
i'll i'll tell them like here's the best
advice i can give you you know there's a
bunch of other people who know stuff i
don't know i was on the phone earlier
with another big you know independent
media organization asking them for
advice
and uh i see these people on twitter and
they like to you know these people with
almost no followers
who just complain about the government
all day and stuff and i'm like i kind of
got no problem they're coming out
playing out the government complain
about the wrong thing but they make fun
of people for not being college-educated
and they specifically come after me for
not finishing high school and i'm just i
want to stop and ask them like what is
the point of your life like what are
your life goals do you want to fit in do
you want to look around the room and say
i've accomplished something
to you is that having a degree
because to me i don't care what you
think i just care about doing cool stuff
you know what i mean so so as i'm
growing up i never saw the point of how
a degree or diploma would would do
anything to help me achieve my goals and
my dreams and these people who pursued
that are now laden with student loan
debt they want the government to pay it
off for them and they're insulting me
for running a successful business
because i didn't finish high school it's
completely backwards i think they
genuinely do not understand what life is
and so they just complain and they're
scared and confused well there's a
there's a way that the system coddles
kind of comfort and and makes you
adverse to any kind of uh you know
things that you have to actually work
for and whether it's just blinding
yourself with pleasure or entertainment
or video games the system right now is
literally i believe priming you to live
in a box to be a part of a vr metaverse
technological world where you have all
your pleasures just delivered right to
you when it comes to actually
sacrificing when it comes to actual hard
work when it comes to actual pain that
those are virtues that are not taught to
individuals they're they're there in our
society it's it's looked upon as
something negative but it but it's
something that of course makes life as
amazing and it's worth living for with
those things in it yeah i would also say
this when people sort of look down on
you for your level of education even
though you have a very successful
business there's something ironic about
that because particularly with the
purpose of modern education it's more or
less to get people credentialed so that
you can predict their future success so
to say well you don't have the predictor
of the success that you ended up having
is a backwards way of looking at it
i think at this point and i've talked a
lot about it higher education is
basically just it's put people in this
isolated space where they become
indoctrinated not necessarily on purpose
i know there's a lot of professors that
do try to indoctrinate obviously but
when you take a bunch of people and put
them in an environment where they're not
actually going to learn anything
meaningful for the most part i mean
obviously they might learn about the
great works and and the great quotes but
i mean can they fix a toilet can they
can they repair their car can they
balance a checkbook did they learn
fights a lot of people go to school for
things that don't make sense no yeah so
so what happens when you take all of
these people put them in this room they
develop no meaningful skills release
them into the world they're confused why
they don't fit into society and they get
angry about it they demand the
government change everything for them
but if they did the system would
collapse because these are not the
people propping the system up you want
to know who's popping the system system
up very very obviously i know it it's
almost ad nauseam at this point truckers
transferring the goods carpenters
tradesmen contractors plumbers
electricians
all like i tell you man
get any degree in the world you want
you will you will need a plumber
a hundred times more often than you will
need someone with a degree in you know
from a liberal post-modern literature or
something like that yeah like i i read
marx and i read uh all of these great
works about communism like can you fix
my toilet or not dude i don't know what
you're talking about i'm wondering i'm
thinking about the difference between iq
and eq that's intelligence quotient and
emotional quotient and kind of how the
idea of intellect is you could probably
divide it into both and i wonder if it's
the struggle of the blue-collar work
that develops eq that it's the pain of
like having to do something you don't
necessarily want to do that you learn
like
how to deal with emotions eq's you're
going to stop your identity no no i got
to stop you right there what do you mean
you don't want to do what does that mean
like it's it's it's stressful jobs that
are stressful what
a job that is stressful is the job that
you don't want to do and that could be
any job in the world well like this job
is not stressful to me i used to chop
wood that was really hard and that's for
you and there are a lot of people i know
that are like i could never sit in a
seat and talk about this kind of stuff
i'd be so embarrassed and insecure i'd
rather just chop wood man i know i know
people who work hvac who are like i
tried doing other stuff but this really
is where i just feel the most useful
like when we have a contractor come in
here and you get a guy who's like just
like a regular you know
laborer
and he doesn't know anything about hdmi
chords or 4k or whatever and then he's
like oh you got a support problem in
your wall i'm like please help me
because i have no idea how to fix that
that's that's a person who's passionate
about their job who says i can solve
this problem for you they feel good
about their job
anybody can feel good about their job
the issue is we're taking these young
people we're putting them in colleges
and telling them to be astronauts and
rock stars y'all should have watched
fight club because tyler durden told you
right then that's not what you're going
to be learn something meaningful mike
rowe says it i want to push back a
little bit he said don't follow your
passions follow what you say follow your
talents i said don't follow your passion
let your passion follow you basically
take your passion with you to whatever
job yes right yeah right right i think
you know we have too many people who
want to be
acknowledged
but but they want to be on tv they want
to be influencers they want all the
likes but you could just be a really
really great electrician and then you go
and work a job and you're going to have
some family and they're going to be like
you are a lifesaver we had no idea what
the problem was that the refrigerator
went out our food was spoiling
he came in snapped his fingers and
solved all of our problems lifesaver
just really quick don't watch fight club
if you're in china because the
government there just edited the ending
of it but second of all uh you know life
has a lot of ups and downs it's a crazy
ride but they're trying to incentivize
that it's only going to be up but again
you can't have the up if you don't have
the down but but this is why the world
economic forum a part of their 2030
pledge for not owning anything not
having any privacy was also that you'll
be happy this is what the system uses in
order to incentivize everyone because
they make you miserable on purpose they
create the circumstances in your life
where you are indebted unhappy
unsatisfied and a little worker bee
slave for their establishment and then
they're like but we'll give you all the
happiness just give us more of your
liberty more of your freedom whatever
your responsibility don't you don't have
to you don't have to sacrifice and work
hard those are bad things and when you
teach people not to sacrifice not to
work hard you literally create little
lemmings you create the perfect slaves
are going to be perfect for the
establishment to have as their little
peons to do whatever they wanted to do
with because then you get rid of
personal responsibility and people's
internal strength but let's let's let's
have an honest conversation about this
right
when you have an ever increasing quality
of life when people today live better
than you know the richest people 100
years ago when your dental care is
better than rockefellers when your
cancer treatment is better than
rockefeller's and all the you know the
the oil barons and the robber barons or
whatever
at a certain point
that kind of increased
quality of life it can't sustain itself
so what i think happens is you end up
with these these millennials who were
told life will be better than it was
than your your the the life your parents
led your life will be better
now it's not as good but it's all
relative you know what i mean 100 years
ago if you took a poor person and
brought them into the average apartment
with clean running water hot water air
conditioning and a refrigerator they'd
be like you must be a billionaire like
wow or a millionaire because of
inflation it wasn't as high that back
then but they would think you were like
a king it's like no no this is just
everybody gets it
so what's happening with the global
elites is they're trying to take all
that away from you so they can trickle
it back really slowly it's the idea that
harry tubman said harry tommen said i
freed many slaves i would have freed
many more if only they knew they were
slaves they take away all of these
luxuries from you
then once you have nothing
they'll make you happy by giving you
point one percent back
and it's it's worse than just taking
away
right now this is why they talk about
population control all the time sorry
i don't i think not only do they re
relieve you of your luxuries but they'll
induce suffering and then remove a
little bit of suffering and call it
happiness but it's relative so
covet happens they destroy everyone's
business they make everybody
uncomfortable and angry people start
losing their minds crime skyrockets
now they can go well save you and they
slowly starbucks they cause the problem
make you angry once you get used to it
they reduce the problem they cause a
little bit and you feel a little bit
more relieved you see how that works
call that happiness that's right
fleeting they say you're happy now right
you're happy well this is why they've
been trying to restrict people's ability
to travel to eat red meat and to live a
life of freedom and personal
responsibility because when you have
that they have less themselves and
they're utter control freaks a lot of
them are sociopaths they believe in this
unrealistic idea of population control
and population reduction for the
betterment of the world which is
absolutely a ridiculous idea that has
been debunked by many different
scientists and different studies and
different data sets already out there
but they still keep pushing it as if if
it's the norm and now they're trying to
push an agenda where we destroy the
family unit because when we destroy the
family unit there's going to be a lot
less people out there which means a lot
more resources for the billionaire class
a lot less for everyone else because
they're not reproducing i was kind of
thinking that um
with the current economic trajectory
we're on for globally with china set to
take over
maybe a lot of these elites have just
said you know what why resist it who
cares who's in charge as long as they
protect themselves and their assets and
so it kind of feels in many ways
this may be good for americans in the
long run bad in a lot of ways but good a
lot of ways that we get our freedoms we
we restore you know balance in this
country but china does take over and
then it asserts you know serious
authority over the rest of the planet
but i kind of feel like
it's possible that trajectory for
china's rampant growth is inevitable
and that's why it's like we're kind of
just spinning our wheels here you know i
see it differently just really i just
really wanted to make this point because
it just brought so many important
aspects that i really just want to talk
about really quickly you know there's a
reason henry kissinger and david
rockefeller opened up china to the rest
of the world there's a reason
individuals like bill gates and other
multinational billionaire corporate
entities are the one advising china and
propping up china to be as powerful and
as prominent as they are right now and
and i think it's it's not what you said
to him that i see it differently i see
it as the corporate elites trying to
bring in the chinese model into the rest
of the world so we are uh under a social
credit score we are living like we are
in china with the government centralized
and controlling every aspect of our
existence i think that's the end game i
think that's where they're trying to go
and i think kobit was an excuse for them
to try to initiate a lot of their
programs and initiatives in order to
make that happen sorry go ahead champion
you know i i also wouldn't assume that
china is together enough to have any
real long-term success their economy is
developing right now but first of all
they're going to hit a birth dirt they
already have had a birth to earth
because they don't they don't have
enough women to
insell apocalypse yeah they're gonna
have their in-sell apocalypse they're
they're not gonna be having children at
a proper replacement rate and you've
sort of mentioned how that could be
grounds for some kind of conquest for
them but there's only so far you can go
with that i genuinely believe that the
more comfortable china becomes the more
their citizen ring is gonna become like
our own in many ways and i'm referring
specifically to the unfortunate aspects
of our citizenry they're not going to be
as interested in virtue or
self-development or even in family and i
think their system is going to rot
within and then we on the other hand
will likely face some very difficult
times and i think that's going to result
in the average person becoming more
virtuous and so there really is cause
for hope here well let's let's talk
about a cause for hope because the one
thing that breaks all of this is
independent media and we got the story
from the independent john stewart sides
with joe rogan as more artists leave
spotify this overreaction is a mistake
neil young joni mitchell blah blah blah
then crosby stills and nash then not
roxanne gay i believe her name is she's
pulling her her podcast i don't know
what her podcast is but she does have
800 some thousand followers on twitter
so she it's probably not nothing but
check this out
in what may be the weirdest turn in the
joe rogan story mike.com reports
brazil's far-right president is thirsty
for joe rogan on main
excellent headline mike
really really desperate but uh we get
your point
bolsonaro tweeted i'm not sure what joe
rogan thinks about me or my government
but it doesn't matter if freedom of
speech means anything it means that
people should be free to say what they
think no matter if they agree or
disagree with us stand your ground hugs
from brazil we also have el salvador
what is this
specifically saying um you know uh you
know what what kind of sarcasm freedom
of the press is under attack in el
salvador but he did the the spongebob
sarcasm yeah
joe rogan
joe yeah the controversy around you has
reached international incident
proportions
i thought this was over we talked about
it it's been like a month now um i'm
honestly i was kind of like okay okay
where are we doing this but let's just i
just
how
what's going on man
we live in a world where the president
is demented
who who do you see the video of uh jill
holding his hand and walking him and
he's like fumbling around like confused
our president's lost his mind he's
deploying troops we've got
the fear factor guy is the most
influential media personality in the
world
this is it just it's just it's it's
quite the narrative crumbles under truth
and they can't have people speaking the
truth because when they do it literally
obliterates everything that they're
trying to accomplish which they would
never be able to do if people were in
the dark and they were ignorant so they
have to shut people down and there has
been a consorted multinational corporate
effort to shut down joe rogan the white
house has been making statements saying
that they need to do more to fight
misinformation
pretty much
you know alluding to the fact that they
need to censor joe rogan so when you
have pressure from the u.s government
when you have pressure from the esg
you know environmental social governance
credit score when you have major banks
and investment firms coming to you
saying hey get rid of him take him out
we got to censor him that's a lot of
pressure but
and and but it also stands true to the
important messages that he releases yeah
i'm loving this because
i'm pretty sure all of this
has increased joe rogan's influence oh
yeah tremendously a full order of
magnitude or more yes now there's
something i want to point out about this
uh this story so firstly i want to
mention this jon stewart he made a lot
of the right noises he mentioned that
this is an overreaction unfortunately he
ends up saying something along the lines
of
you know the real problem is that the
algorithms are promoting misinformation
which is kind of what we hear from
left-wing people who want to censor this
type of thing but i i think that he
might just be misled there stewart does
not come come across as the kind of guy
who wants the sensor one thing i wanted
to point out though tim at the end of
the article on the independent
about this we have a little blurb
that uh a misinformation a
misinformation researcher called the
warning labels on his podcasts
too little too late you know who that
misinformation researcher is
abby richards
the conspiracy theory pyramid so so
sheamus made one of one of your best uh
works
he analyzed abby richards conspiracy
theory pyramid and she actually is it's
the most insane thing i've ever seen
this woman who's considered an expert
question questions the iran contra
scandal like that's not we know that
happened
and so what she said in response yeah
exactly so what she said in response to
that was oh well like i'm questioning
reagan's involvement but
the point is kind of moot because she's
had to remake her conspiracy theory
hierarchy pyramid scale more than once
because things on it literally turned
out to be true so she had to remove them
yeah i just want to make this point for
luke while luke is here
she makes this pyramid where on the it's
like small on the bottom it gets bigger
on the top and as you get higher up it
all of a sudden is like anti-semitic
conspiracy theory alert and it's like
hollow earth but one of the things she
had on one of her original pyramids was
bill gates microchipping people
and she had to remove it
because bill gates is developing birth
control microchips for people there you
go luke um take it out she had covered
lab leak under uh she got rid of c3s as
well she had to get rid of that there
was another one i'm not sure if it would
be too obscene to mention on air but
there was another one she mentioned
where the with the hollow earth used the
lord of the rings the father yes no
that's right
it's funny because she took the words
deep state as a conspiracy theory and
she put them in his own she calls the
anti-semitic point of no return but then
lower down on the pyramid someone
pointed out
she has fbi spied on mlk
it's like wait so do you love having a
deep state or not
she calls the like if you believe in
hollow earth you're an anti-semite yeah
which is crazy if you believe in a deep
state but then you made a really funny
point in saying that she's the
conspiracy theorist accusing all of
these conspiracies of being connected
yes exactly she calls them all justin
she also says they're all connected so
like believing the deep state is like
connected to believing in hollow earth
and like all this these absurd tenuous
connections so go watch the video if you
can bring it all together called leftist
meme reviews like the opposite of alex
jones yeah no no no
well yeah but to bring it all together
this is someone being quoted in the
mains in a mainstream news source in a
corporate corporate press
about accusing joe rogan of being
misinformation and she had to remake her
conspiracy chart because she got it
wrong so much she literally said
multiple things were called conspiracy
theories that were too dangerous to
believe on her chart that literally
turned out to be true so she had to
remove them
from updates i'm having a good time look
at this we got this story this spotify
ceo is defending joe rogan again
saying that there will be opinions and
beliefs that we disagree with but
they're not in the business of dictating
discourse i want to give a special shout
out to joe because he's done something
tremendous for all of us
by being on spotify unity did he
basically just built a 30-foot beautiful
concrete wall from sea to shining sea
because what happens now is spotify made
they staked a claim on his show they say
we need this to make money we want this
show
the more joe has on controversial
figures the more we on our podcasts are
able to have on controversial figures as
well
because when they the ceo coming out now
and saying well there's going to be
people we disagree with
yep because they can't ban joe so joe
becomes the baseline for what is
basically allowed and if joe's going to
talk to robert malone and peter
mccullough everyone else can too yeah
this is they still might hold a double
standard mind you but it sets that limit
we don't need his permission though we
can do it we can pioneer it as well it's
not about his permission it's about
spotify is now in in the position of
being like
but if we ban them people are going to
come at us about rogan and we don't want
to lose that money so just dude stop
stop he's pushing the overton window
with what is acceptable to even be
talked about and when he's talking to
mainline medical professionals that big
tech social media companies censor like
people who are accredited people who are
in the field of mrna vaccines people who
literally helped develop them he's
bringing information and knowledge that
is becoming sacred but he's making it
mainstream he's absolutely obliterating
the official narrative just by simply
questioning it he's not making
statements he's talking to individuals
from both sides he's not just
interviewing conspiracy theorists or
crazies or or people who are on the
french he's also interviewing sanjay
gupta of all people there's no way to
attack this individual so they literally
make stuff up out of nowhere and they're
trying to destroy him not even on any
significant charges they don't have
anything what do they have on him the
only way for the left to win is through
authoritarianism
and i'll be i'll be real i've talked
about it before when you look at the
political compass you're talking about
economic left and like uh libertarian so
left libertarians it is life on hard
mode this idea that you're going to
convince everyone to cooperate and agree
outside of capital is is is almost a
pipe dream i think it's fantastic but
only works at really small scales so as
the left starts gaining more and more
power the only way to convert people
because they're gonna fundamentally
disagree with you is through force
so they ban people they censor you look
at all these countries that's that's how
they have to pull it off they smeared
bolsonaro so hard i thought this guy was
like a lunatic for the last couple years
when i've just the media has been
talking about this far right
authoritarian brazilian guy and i'm like
okay here we go we got another hard-line
nazi in power but it turns out this guy
supports american free speech and is
going to speak up for joe rogan
well john stewart made a good point he
said you know instead of just trying to
cancel someone debate that person he
didn't say it exactly like that but he
said counter their points what points
are they countering that joe rogan has
made what arguments are they going
against
was forced to admit he was lying you
know what's really funny you take sanjay
out of his protective bubble and all of
a sudden he is like
yeah it was not true shouldn't have said
that we shouldn't have said that it was
a bumbling buffoon and then went on cnn
the next day and said and contradicted
himself which was crazy and said oh yeah
i didn't mean that it's kind of
hilarious though it's like everyone
could see both what was he thinking
like
talk smack about somebody to their face
or i'm sorry behind their back like on
air yeah yeah you're not behind their
back when you're on air
well you're on cnn you don't get that
many viewers now let's be fair he kind
of had faith no one would see it the
only way the left is able to maintain
any kind of narrative is through
sophistry yeah manipulating withholding
information censoring shutting people
down i think if cnn and msnbc went out
of business tomorrow like just
disappeared things the world would
change dramatically i i don't i don't
know if i agree really yeah somebody
would reply some it would be young turks
or something like that and to be honest
their ratings are so so far down in the
gutter so you think you can't i guess
erasing the the channel is different
than erasing the methodology you think
the methodology is just going to
perpetuate oh yeah
yeah you look you're always going to
have people who are willing to lie for
money and you're always going to have
people with a set political agenda who
are okay misleading the public and
maddow's gone anyway
she's she's she's her show's changing i
guess was like once a week and then
she's she's out for two weeks so she's
basically just like
you know she's she's cashed out as much
as he could ripping off these people i
love i love how these people go on
twitter and they're like they're all
right-wing grifters
it's like yo rachel maddow and brian
salter and don lemon and chris cuomo
like cuomo literally pretended he was
under quarantine you guys are getting
ripped off like crazy it's it's sad man
it is but i wonder how many of those
people like they know it and they're
just enforcers for these evil people
right like they're not
how many how many of these people who
are supporting them
actually believe it or know it's a lie
but are in on it and helping
i think there's a big proportion of it
that's evil i think that there's a
reason some of them get caught doing
spirit cooking and all the horrible
things i think it gets even far worse
far deeper than we could even imagine i
think we're only scratching the surface
with just how bad some of these people
are and then on the other half there are
some dumb people who are just following
along and repeating the things just to
be accepted as in yeah i think there's
also a third group here which is
people who genuinely believe in the
cause and they do this very dangerous
thing which is rationalized telling lies
in order to get their agenda across
people will convince themselves that it
isn't wrong to lie about something if
they think the greater good will come
about through telling that lie and i
think that's true in a very large
majority of cases when it comes to these
news reporters because they're saying
things that at some point they have to
know aren't true
so
and i think they're able to rationalize
that by saying i'm one of the good guys
what i want for the world
is better than what these republicans
want for the world and they're willing
to lie to get it so why don't i do the
same you need a lot of drugs to be in
that state to be honest with you and i
highly doubt there's a lot of them but i
know i i know i think it's actually very
common they're children
they have a children's view they view
the world digitally like
we are at point a and we'd like to get
to point c and that means point b is
going to be brutal dictatorship the
point c is beautiful they believe the
ends justify the means because they have
the mentality of toddlers but the danger
is because they don't they don't realize
that you never meet the end if your end
goal was the extermination of all
humanity okay well then i understand
you'd say the ends justify the means
because we're going to get to the end in
about five years if we enact this policy
but if you're if your goal is we want to
create a socialist utopia and we're
willing to wipe out you know people to
get it then how do you defend your new
utopia from the next revolution it's the
same tired story there is no end you
there's maintenance after you achieve
your goal and maintenance using those
strategies is just despotism
authoritarianism dictatorship fascism
etc i saw a friend of mine from
one of my best friends from childhood we
were having an adult conversation in our
30s this is like three or four years ago
after trump got elected and he was like
we need to use their tactics against
them that's fascist we need to use i
don't know if he was saying street
violence um coercion he was like we will
you whatever and i thought said you you
have to understand
that you're becoming the demon that you
want to destroy if you're doing that
it's the the the process is the
destiny explain and it was so disturbing
to hear an adult that i have trusted my
entire life say these things to me after
we've been through it together and
talked about how you can't use the evil
methodology to defeat evil it's
impossible but but still he's
brainwashed well yeah but i would say
it's even worse than that ian you said
it it's sort of like trying to um you
become the beast to defeat the beast but
when he's saying we need to use street
violence against these trump supporters
we need to use their tactics against
them what street violence is he talking
about i think it was the proud boys
antifa kerfuffle but the proud boys
weren't starting those fights it's all
whatever the media made them think i
didn't ask exactly so what happens is
oftentimes a person will think i'm
fighting fire with fire when they were
just propagandized to think the other
side was using fire in the first place
so they're just attacking innocent
people
that's exactly what it is the far left
goes out and says we're defending
ourselves as they burn down small
businesses it is it is psychotic and
they believe the ends justify the means
they're like well if we burn down these
buildings then in one year we'll have a
utopia it's like yo that's not gonna
happen because the guy who's who's
building you burned down he's gonna come
back with his own group of people
protesting against you for being violent
psychopaths yeah and the children of the
people getting bombed in the middle east
are gonna remember that their entire
life there's a great song
about this that i heard it's called will
of the people it's by uh tim cass oh
yeah yeah and it shows the cycle of
timothy cast right that's right yeah
yeah shout out it's a song that i wrote
the cycle never ends it only begins
again that's right yeah so at the end of
the of the song like one of the uh well
i don't well if you've many of you've
probably already seen it's called wild
people people are pulling down the
statue but every time they pull it down
it just rotates and another one comes up
not my idea that was a piece of artwork
based on on the arab spring that every
time they pull one statue of a dictator
down it just springs up the next one
that's what it is and these people don't
understand that there's always a cycle
of authoritarianism of violence that
that's why the best thing you can do is
build a system right now that respects
people's fundamental rights doesn't
engage in these tactics
and that's literally how you get your
utopia yeah when you have freedom you
have prosperity it's that simple when
you have governments controlling every
aspect of your existence destroying
capital and destroying the free flow of
it you have again the down aggression
and the the the downgrading of humanity
let's piss off youtube and talk about
guns uh-oh
joe biden says uh fox news reports biden
repeats debunked second amendment cannon
claim says no amendment is absolute this
guy i look i think joe biden is demented
yeah i think he's just generally not
there
true in a nunna shop at the pressure if
you know what i mean better calf care he
he says gibberish
he's got harry
sit on my lap
from the washington post where democracy
dies in darkness
biden's false claim the second amendment
bans cannon ownership ladies and
gentlemen
not only could you actually buy cannons
back then when they drafted the
constitution and he was there
right you can buy cannons right now
it's it's like
joe biden just makes this stuff up i i
honestly believe he knows he's lying but
he says this because he's trying to
change the cultural perspective of
americans he wants americans to go
around saying lies it's really annoying
when i have these lefty people i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry left i shouldn't say
lefty people because the left likes guns
the liberal establishment democrat types
i can't stand it when they're like calm
down no one's trying to take your guns
away and i was like my bear my barrett
m82 is banned in this state this state
this date and then they go well but why
would you need that hey don't change
don't move the goalposts my flamethrower
was banned in maryland i want to have my
flamethrower here i can't waco
yes yeah yes not trying to take our guns
joe biden is a liar yes and you take a
look at what's going on the truckers who
mentioned this last night
the military is concerned about going in
and rounding people up because they
might be armed not so so you don't need
guns to engage in active conflict it
prevents active conflict it is a force
balancer joe biden wants to crack down
and take people's guns as they always
this is biden's doj plan and gun crime
prioritize gun violence crackdown on
trafficking
national ghost gun enforcement
initiative pursue gun sellers of illegal
guns 500 million reducing gun crime yo
they've been they they tried several
years ago banning all semi-automatic
weapons yep they put the proposed insane
because no one knows what semi-automatic
means that's the problem there's people
who don't have guns don't know what
the the liberal they they they do this
all the time and i think a lot of it's
on purpose they'll take a picture of a
rifle and call it an automatic weapon
yes
it's a slight it's a verbal sleight of
hand yep because they can say oh well
like i meant semi-automatic which is a
type of automatic it's like come on you
know what you're doing yo it's just like
with the joe rogan thing they don't know
what they're talking about they don't
care what they're talking about they
just want a virtue signal and there's a
very serious problem
i said it before i'll say it again
michael malus likes to say how could you
possibly be black-pilled when you see
how stupid these people are and i'm just
like yo
a zombie is stupid but a thousand of
them are formidable and can take over a
city and then convert people into
zombies and all that stuff so when i see
hordes of people on twitter who have no
idea what they're talking about
covington kids
you wanna know what worries me the
covington kid incident shows how a large
group of npcs can destroy the life of of
teenagers
and
what could what could be done now we
effectively countered that exactly prove
the lies but it doesn't always happen
that way look at russiagate
no i mean you're right we don't always
win but i think people are starting to
wake up to it and there are reasons to
be white-pilled and their stupidity is
one of those reasons i remember when i
was looking at the footage of nick
sandman a couple years ago you had the
black hebrew israelites there and the
way the media reported on it was that
they were young african-american men
preaching about the bible and oppression
which is a hilarious way of
characterizing that if you have any idea
what the black people write yeah these
are things that would get your channel
banned if i said them out loud but
you were also talking a little bit
earlier about the fact that
lefties really do like gun crime
uh or i'm sorry i don't like gun crime
they actually don't have a problem with
guns
and it's true and you sort of mentioned
establishment liberal types tend to be
more likely to be in favor of gun
control but one thing i found is a lot
of the more like milk toast
establishment democrat liberals i know
say that the one conservative position
they have is that they're against gun
control it is a losing issue for the
left overall and i think there's a white
pill there as well i just want to
mention as a as an absolute aside to
derail yeah part of the reason i just
want to say part of the reason i got
tripped up verbally there is because tim
was like standing messing with things on
the table luke very roykowski luke broke
yep our fouchy bobblehead i was really
decorating i tried to stop him he wanted
to put the gorilla on top of that yes i
was redecorating and then we were
working on on a thumb for the vlog where
the gorilla was with fauci with with
samus's face
there was some emotion action that was
happening for the for the luke
you are literally your credibility
is a journalist
how do we get the rights to that song by
celine
it was childish it was ridiculous i
tried to put a stop to it anyone who
watches the vlog is going to know that
luke is lying you just undermined your
credibility as a journalist your
career's over anyway
what were we talking about something
about we were talking about we're having
this child we're talking about and then
luke comes in with his shenanigans this
was before the show first of all we were
talking about specifically how when
governments disarm citizens historically
this usually leads to a lot of
atrocities always does always
do this for me also what i'm saying
democrats even establishment democrats
the actual constituents are generally
against gun control right right right so
let me let me ask the audience a
question i'd like to ask the audience oh
can you name a country for me where they
enacted
extreme gun control measures and then
people didn't lose their rights right
afterwards or like that you know or
there wasn't a massacre or downside no
no no no i mean australia's not they're
they're they've lost their rights i
don't know you know right right so
here's the issue the issue might be that
we're all just losing our rights anyway
regardless of whether or not they took
our guns but oh but this is the thing so
you're absolutely correct that if people
stand by their rights are taken away but
when you look at for example the freedom
convoy and the fact that the police were
too afraid to do anything about it
because they thought those truckers
might be armed it goes to show that when
people do stand for themselves even if
they as an individual don't have a gun
the idea that they could have a gun is
enough to stop the government from
cracking and this idea of personal
responsibility of firearms is it's a
it's an idea that's becoming more
popular even amongst the left especially
when we look at it from a state by state
issues the the people's ability to be
able to defend themselves is
dramatically going up on a state level
because people are realizing hey the
government is absolutely not working in
the benefit of the general public when
there's a pandemic they're they're
firing hospital workers when there's a
supply chain crisis they're limiting the
amount of trucks that could go through
the border when there's a financial
crisis they're spending more money when
there's a potential war they're firing
members of the military for for not
following their vax mandates they're
doing the exact opposite of what they
should be doing they do not care about
you and the only person responsible for
you yourself as an individual is
yourself and no one else and people
realize that more than ever because the
the lie and the mystery of government is
being unraveled right in front of them
and people are saying hey i got to be
dependent on myself and no one else i'm
hearing this this impassioned plea from
luke very seriously standing on the
soapbox demanding that people stand up
for their rights and it's very difficult
to take seriously because of his shirt
yeah hey you got to call these players
out because these are big players that
are pushing these agendas that are
trying to america trying to turn america
into communist china where the people
are disarmed they disarmed people in
communist china and then what happens
explain your shirt well this this is a
shirt it's a classy elegant shirt that
you should wear at very fancy uh events
uh proper attire and it's a nice photo
of bill gates and mr epstein you know
depicted as the real island boys on
jeffrey epstein's uh he's a little saint
james island
partying and having fun staring at this
while luke is like you must preserve
your rights and stand up
i know it's ridiculous you know it's not
ridiculous it's a very serious shirt
that should bring attention to the very
close bromance that bill gates had with
jeffrey epstein that was far more
extensive which which with their common
three population control that they they
loved and shared and uh you know
there's a reason the corporate media
doesn't want to talk about it
gates told us epstein was giving him
marriage advice right i don't know about
that no no no i don't think he said that
right
i think said he died and he was dead and
there's no reason to talk about i will
say this that was crazy
he was like what does it matter he's
dead
they're like so what do you think about
how did he feel about it you saw he died
a relationship with him looking back and
he's like well you know he's dead
oh my god
as well hey i was correct now to be fair
this is uh the daily beast but headline
jeffrey epstein gave bill gates advice
on how to end his quote toxic marriage
so who's the source on that this is i
mean it's the daily beast you're gonna
question hey yeah exactly
i don't trust the dude hold on hey new
york post yeah exactly new york bus luke
is just gonna disagree with everything i
said he's gonna go i don't trust that
source then he's gonna be like i went to
like
conspiracy.blogspot.net and i heard that
bill gates and jeffrey upstairs a lot
more credible than the the corporate
media
to be fair to be honest be fair you're
not controlling policy theories have
been spoiler alert
disclosed tv legit because i keep seeing
like new media new news pops up on it
and it's like is this as far as like
well yeah just as far as i can tell
they're good so i i follow disclose.tv
on twitter they're just an aggregator
and and it's so whenever i see them
tweet something i always verify anybody
tweet something i'll see it i'll try and
verify sources i try and find what the
root source of it is disclose tends to
just be aggregating legitimate news
sources all right yeah good so you're
saying that the new york post reported
that
bill gates asked epstein for marriage
advice yeah
that he gave him uh advice on his quote
toxic marriage
i don't know why that's so funny to me
that like either of them would refer to
marriage and these like well it was it
was allegedly because of his
relationship with epstein why uh bill
gates's wife divorced him because it was
coming to light and because he refused
to stop hanging out with jeffrey epstein
dude bill gates's wife was like you know
like i don't think it i think it's a
little weird that this guy has this
island and that seems like she's toxic
bro
you have to get away from her toxic
femininity
she's a toxic woman you gotta stay with
i'm your only friend bill meet a girl
like elaine man she'll follow you
anywhere
oh man it's like i wish i had there's a
shirt
which one find a woman
that loves you the way gillane loved
jeffrey and followed them all
we have delaine maxwell did not uh you
know off herself shirt as well what's up
that one's ahead of its time did she get
convicted because i stopped following
the court case yes and we're waiting for
sentencing and we're going to see what's
going to happen but they're also calling
for a mistrial because there's a retrial
yeah yeah because because they're saying
one of the jurors was was tempered
tampered with and had previous uh
instances of also being uh hurt as a
child uh and therefore it implicated the
case here but it's it's amazing that
they've they've not implicated any of
the uh people who are that who are part
of the trafficking you know what i mean
yeah like it's like they ran an illicit
business with really horrible things
okay who's buying and purchasing all
those horrible elicits if only he had
footage of everyone who went there and
did anything illegal if only he had been
filming that stuff and then after if
only there was a sale to find the
footage if only they were crazy safe
with with fbi labels on them already you
know
if only that would happen can you
imagine what a crazy world there's more
conspiracy i just gotta
i just i just want to point out to
everybody
that uh this show gets between its clips
and like the live show like like almost
a million and a half two million and
we're sitting here talking about bill
gates and epstein i absolutely love it
yeah we're winning i'm investigating
absolutely winning we've got to get
tired of winning we're winning so much
the people who are hearing this every
day all day every day
of course they're trying to censor us of
course they're trying to censor
everybody else you know they've gone
really hard against stephen crowder
they're obviously going aft after joe
rogan but i'm just sitting here listen
to luke's wearing a shirt with bill
gates and epstein on it and we're
broadcasting this out to like 50 000
concurrent people you know we'll get
like half a million in total on the
episode you're trying to get banned
right now
it's like we're here
i mean
with you but i'm just saying even if it
was just right now i'm like we stood
atop that hill and held up that picture
for all of these people to see you're
right yeah we are the narrative is
shattering their control is shattering
the people are winning i just just feels
good you know but it's like it's like
dipping our toes into hot lava like
seeing all this stuff is like now we
finally see the hot lava let's find out
oh that's that's too hot i'm not jumping
in i don't want to know who was at
epstein's island necessarily i do i do
but i don't want to get killed in my
sleep so i don't want to talk about it
it's hot lava let's figure out another
way to investigate the livestream hold
on let me ask you something if there was
anything worth getting killed in your
sleep for example like the way you think
exactly thank you i actually agree with
seamus thank you my goodness i'm a smart
guy you should listen to me more often i
question that but but but that other
point but that point you made
specifically about
life being challenging and going up
against the biggest evils being
worthwhile and and making something
extremely challenging for yourself is a
great point that you bring up here
because we're going at the tip of the
spear we're going after some of the most
powerful most sinister most horrible
individuals on the face of this earth
who do unspeakable things we only know a
shred of of what actually is behind this
whole freaking system that is riddled
with so many people getting hurt so many
children being hurt in unspeakable ways
there's so many monsters out there and
if there's anything you should dedicate
your life to in this existence is to
fighting those monsters and protecting
the innocent and this is important work
that needs to be done and i thank you
guys for giving me the opportunity to
even speak about some of these issues it
is because
we
recognize the risks in speaking out
about these things and accept them and
speak about them anyway that we're
winning it's because
joe rogan stands in the face of these
people trying to cancel them and says
i'm going to have these conversations
these guys are credentialed they're
they're well respected i just want to
have these conversations he tries to be
polite about it but they're if we if
we're the kind of people that were like
well we shouldn't bring up some of the
darkest and most dangerous subjects now
i'll be completely honest with you guys
there's censorship
we we have to navigate this minefield
same as anybody else
so we use rumble so we set up at
timcast.com so we put episodes that get
a little spicy on rumble to make sure
the conversations will persist
it's not a perfect scenario we are in a
conflict over our right to speak our
minds but we are actively navigating
that that landscape to make sure we do
this was not possible several decades
ago we can come on youtube when we when
we get issues on youtube we put them up
on rumble and our episode with darren
beatty is our biggest podcast ever with
like 2.4 million views
because when they come after us we put
it up and even more people get to see it
they can try and censor us but we are
not backing down we recognize you know
we're like i said navigating a minefield
but we're going to keep pushing and
making sure the conversations happen in
an intelligent way with alternatives and
backups where they can't get us and they
can't screw us over and even when they
do when they attack us they only prop us
up joe rogan's viewership is
dramatically increasing right now more
than it ever probably has before with so
many governments with so many
corporations attacking him trying to
silence him they only strengthen his
voice and everyone else with the ability
of the opportunities we have in front of
us right now to change the world for the
better i i'd be willing to bet joe's
probably been hit up more to go on his
show now than ever before oh yeah
absolutely from everybody because
they're like this is the platform but i
mean he's like he's hosting robert
malone and the people who are in the
know know and they're interested now
with all this craziness you've probably
got some pr guide is like you got to get
some controversy going on joe rogan's
show it's going to be big buzz and then
they're going to make a big stink about
it and then you're going to be the look
at robert malone is a household name now
because of this story peter mccullough
as well also a mainline doctor that has
the credentials he's not a ques he's not
a crazy person he's not a conspiracy
theorist these are medical professionals
bringing forward data and information
for americans to consume and to
critically think about and the
establishment is losing their ish over
it they're becoming so desperate they're
becoming so pathetic because of data and
information and people realizing that
they have been conned i want you to for
all of you who have seen the movie the
patriot with mel gibson just remember
that scene
when everyone when the line breaks and
they all start retreating but then mel
gibson grabs the american flag and says
oh the line and he just runs the other
direction and then all the the
revolutionary soldiers turn around and
run with them and
that's what it feels like
the mainstream media imploding the
ratings and the gutter there was a time
where i i was pessimistic now i'm
watching cnn just literally erupt in
scandals where cuomo is outing zucker
and he's losing his job and it's
implicating democrats and i'm sitting
back with my feet up laughing
is glorious there's this famous meme of
two people fighting and the guy in the
background kind of smoking a bong
laughing about the whole situation and
then there's a new meme that came out
with cnn fighting cnn and then in the
background is also cnn smoking the box
watching cnn just destroy itself
internally from itself that's literally
what's happening right now and there's
consequences for lying there's
consequences for for distorting reality
and doing the bidding of the special
multi-billion corporate dollar freaking
institutions that are robbing us blinds
there's going to be ramifications for
doing bad things i think those
ramifications are going to be felt more
than ever especially with the cases
coveted cases going dramatically down
and people are realizing hey there was a
lot of things up here that weren't going
to be passing any kind of reality tests
they're canceling themselves over this i
love it they're they're they're like
well i'm going to ban myself from
spotify it's like okay
censor yourself that was always allowed
you know what concerns me about what you
were saying earlier luke about the i
guess the monsters of earth the human
monsters of earth that are doing these
horrible things like even if they
disappeared tomorrow this is kind of
like we were talking about with the
methodology and the
if they were just all disappear you'd
still have monstrous behavior and so
it's like if we spend our life fighting
monsters not only do you yourself become
a target because the monsters want you
dead but there's always going to be more
monsters yeah the price of liberty is
eternal vigilance yes yeah it's
understandable it's okay like i mean
this is do you want challenges in your
life or do you want when you play video
games do you want to be challenged or do
you want easy video games that would
give you everything and give you all the
cheat codes the point challenge exactly
there's a saying that i can't remember
who said it but life is like a treadmill
if you stand still you move backwards if
you walk you stay where you are yeah you
have to run to get ahead
and that's what we're doing every day at
the at the bare minimum in the battle
for in in the constant vigilance for
freedom we are we are walking and
exerting energy to make sure we're
maintaining that and if you want to win
more ground net fight for freedom you
have to be pushing as hard as you can
because at any point you just stop and
stand still they start taking as much as
they can away from you no it's true
it's funny because people will often
speak as though our goal should be to
set up a system that's going to be
perpetually functional and the reality
is you can't do that you just have to
try to find a way to foster a culture
where people are going to be raising
their children with positive
ideas and virtues it but it is eternal
vigilance like luke said that's what you
need i didn't say it was a famous code
it was oh that's about it
no i know that plagiarism i don't know i
don't know i gotta i gotta i gotta talk
slow sometimes when i talk
okay
i get that you're wearing glasses right
now but do you think i think you're that
smart hold on what do you think about
what he thinks about what i think about
what do you think about what i think
about what he thinks about hey how was
florida i hear you were there it's
amazing
i'm not going to answer your
shameless questions you've been in
florida for a couple days dude yes
and it's amazing i came here for a
debate and a conversation to be had
which i was really looking forward to
but it's okay what does it like does
your dna just change can you feel the
vibration when you enter that state i i
i just feel alive i feel really happy
there's there's you know i don't know if
it's just the sun or just the people or
the opportunities there i i just love
being down there and it gives me a lot
of peace of mind and it gives me a lot
of inspiration so um you know i'm happy
i'm sure they love you too just people
need to understand how crazy it is that
for those that live in new york who have
been under permanent lockdown for years
people in florida are just like what
yeah you know it's like going to the
store like normal eating pizza well it
depends where you go there's also a lot
of uh city areas that are also you know
they have the karens and kyle's there
but it's good there's going to be a very
big political fight in florida coming up
in the next few months especially with
the race for for the next governor so
this is going to be a place that's going
to be very important for the future of
this country florida has been leading
the way when it came to challenging a
lot of the stupid narratives out there
and changing the face of the united
states so i i believe the battlegrounds
are in florida and that's why i'm you
know i'm going to be there we had some
plans to go at the end of february i
think those got pushed back well cpac is
in a few days i'm going to be at that
and then there's also the bitcoin
conference happening in a few weeks
which is also going to bring a lot of
major players the issue is that the
person we hired to do our trailer has
just not
we did all this electrical installed for
the mobile yeah but we could probably
work something out and find good
electricity and good internet at a
location where we don't have to depend
on any of that other stuff i mean
tim i could yeah
it's funny tim because you mentioned
people in new york not knowing that
they're not really understanding that
there are parts of the country where
things are somewhat normal for the first
couple months of the lockdown i was up
in illinois and then i ended up escaping
back on down to georgia and the
difference in attitudes was almost
unbelievable it was like nothing was
even happening once i got back down
there people were living their lives
they were like normal healthy human
beings it was very strange it was
jarring for me where we are right now
we are you know in the tri-state with
virginia west virginia maryland
you go into frederick county mass
mandates yeah now on the outskirts of it
they usually they kind of don't bother
you but if you go downtown it's they're
insane they scream
you drive for five minutes and they're
like mask
what what's that what's that why would i
wear one that's why there's so much
economic prosperity in florida right now
because businesses weren't hindered by
the lockdowns or mandates or kicking
their customers out for not following
the decrees of their overlords people
there's a lot of opportunity especially
economic opportunity down there and
things are booming west virginia's doing
well too relatively relatively there was
a funny story in the ap about this this
teacher who lived in west virginia and
she fled the state and everyone i know
like from all the all the facebook
groups in west virginia are like yay
like
these urban liberal teachers are
complaining about things and leaving
good i wonder if in 20 years a bunch of
our leaders are going to be like yeah i
was from florida yeah i'm from florida
too yeah you're from florida yeah i'm
from florida and like all these adults
now that are like normal are because
they came from places that didn't have
to cover their face for two years
and what do you say in 20 years you said
yeah in 20 years yeah in 20 years
there's gonna be like a dude and he's
gonna he's wearing a jean jacket with
the sleeves ripped off and he's gonna
have like he's gonna have like an eye
patch and he's gonna be like are you
from florida and the other guy's gonna
be dressed the same and he's gonna be
like i am too and they're gonna turn
there's gonna be a bunch of npc zombie
people in the post apocalyptic for
florida for florida
it's like you ever play a fallout new
vegas yeah in new vegas for those
unfamiliar fallout is a video game it's
a story universe based on a
post-apocalyptic world and the the u.s
you know all the world is bombed you
know nuclear bombs go off blah blah blah
cities are wiped out in the new vegas
storyline there's the new california
republic which is after the apocalypse
they start rebuilding their government i
got to say now based on what we know
about actual history if i was going to
make a game it would be the new florida
republic uh yeah all the rest of the
country would be in like shambles the
economy would be like a disaster and
then you'd have like parts of texas new
hampshire and florida be like kind of
all right yeah i bet they would recover
louisiana the whole gulf and mexico
maybe start a new country down there
it's you know it's funny what you're
saying about how they're all going to
pretend to be from florida i bet you
that in like 20 years the democrats are
going to the the democrats are going to
be like no we were like way against the
lockdowns like the party switched there
was a big party switch like 10 years ago
you guys remember like we were against
all asks totally not we were telling
people to put pantyhose on their face
that's ridiculous
pandemic we specifically said don't buy
masks
i want to point out uh ian just said
that all of the gulf will form a new
country and i'm just like yeah they
tried that before
ian it didn't work out too oh yeah wait
that was texas right
no the lone star called the civil war
yeah well i'm talking about states we're
like let's get out in like a fall out
scenario it'd be cool to have like a
free a free area of the world on that
they got their own oceans like then we
could do it then the sun will rise again
in a video game
florida man florida's pretty good but uh
i like west virginia you know it's it's
very nice it's got a good mix of seasons
florida man there's coconuts everywhere
yeah i had a yard what's wrong with
coconuts
listen listen yo i had i had a place in
florida it was in the it was in the
redlands which is about like 40 minutes
west of miami southwest it's my
homestead it's where that facility for
migrant kids was placed
we had too many coconuts they were
everywhere like you walked outside and
there was literally a thousand coconuts
along the edge of the yard and i'm like
i don't even know what i'm supposed to
do with all these coconuts there's just
too many
it was me it was awful what do you do
with them all i don't know we just left
them stick a screwdriver i'm a good
entrepreneur and then you build a stand
and then you put them on the stand and
you say coconuts for five dollars each
pick one and then use an honor system i
think the man made a good point
you don't even have to work i think it
was the workflow i think it was like
decades of coconut pile up
and like they were just like uh i don't
know not rotten but like decayed what's
the expiration date i don't know but i'm
being serious when i say there was an
insane amount of coconuts just littering
the property or if you need to shoot
stuff you don't need to have targets you
could have coconuts that you could do
through right i feel like that would be
used for coconuts we had chickens but
the wild critters kept killing them at
least you get four to eight months of
coconut
uh unrefrigerated packaged that's dried
coconut so we actually we tried we we
tried to get up one of the palm trees to
get a fresh coconut down and it was
really hard why did you try this this is
everywhere you get a week because we
wanted a fresh one from the tree right
so we finally ended up getting one down
i can't remember how i think someone
climbed the tree and it was just like it
was a pretty crummy coconut there's like
very little coconut juice in it and we
were like man you go to the store you
get those those coconuts with the so
full of juice or whatever there when i
lived in new york there was a guy who
just like in a safari costume and he had
a machete and he'd put a coconut and
he'd he'd spin it while whacking it yeah
and then he would pour out the coconut
juice scrape it all off into a blender
and then he would press a sugar cane
right there and then blend it up enhance
you it was like the healthiest most
delicious thing ever that's going to be
my goal on what i want to do in my life
i want to be that coconut dude
and i'm probably going to be doing some
kind of survival class i have no idea
how to survive than the tropics i know
how to do like survival trainings in the
north but i'm going to be probably
learning survival training in the
tropics um and if you guys know anyone
that can teach me let me know
hold on luke that's not important what's
important is that scientists find
putting pantyhose on your head makes
your mask safer
after testing seven ways to make masks
seal better on the face researchers
found that a pair of ho ho hosiery
hosiery does the trick best
they're screw with us
at this point look at this image it is
obvious they are screwing with us
there are going to be people who are
going to be wearing pantyhose on their
face
there's people who are going to do this
they're doing a double masking thing
yeah they're doing a bit yeah it
obviously works it it tightens the pole
but so does scotch tape i mean what's
the point
what are they trying to
trying to sell pantyhose they're
literally trying to embarrass you i
think that's what it is like they want
people to be humiliated this really does
look like they're trying to see if they
can get people to do it like there was
some some scientist and he was like hey
but if we tell people to put panties in
their face they'll do it they'll do it
and then they're like they're stoned as
they're like sitting in the lab and it's
like dude i'm gonna i'm gonna write it
up and he's typing go away they're not
gonna fall for it dude tell him you
gotta like pull it extra tight we'll
pull it tight and they're laughing and
they submit it and vice is like oh wow
oh and they publish it these guys are
just like high-fiving each other yeah
they chest a bump and they're like we
did it why is vice making this an
article is the baker question why do
they think it's newsworthy to to
propagate this kind of information to
their audience because they want to save
lives luke
modus operandi
mummy look at this one it's called mummy
oh my gosh so they have a bunch of
different styles of putting a mask on
and they have tying the bands no hack
tape look at that
pantyhose white and pantyhose black dude
this is such colored pantyhose do better
look at that look at the mummy one what
what what does that mean all right dude
mummy the person who made that graphic
does not do any of those things and they
don't know anyone else who does either
what if you saw a mummy guy at the
airport if you saw somebody like that
with their face bandaged like a mummy's
face that'd be so hilarious we have
space helmets that's true yeah you want
okay let's take one of those
so here's the funniest thing though so
we i bought these big plastic helmets
that they were marketing at the start of
the pandemic like why wear a mask when
you can wear this
and you can't hear someone when they're
talking a lot of people point out like
what if you sneeze because it's like a
space helmet and here's the best part
you can't wear them on planes anyway
yeah i still want you wearing a mask
because yeah that's what the rules
saying they follow the rules to the tee
but it is a mask the rules are very
important
it does not work as a mask it has to be
a cloth mask so you have if you want to
wear the space helmet you can literally
be wearing a space helmet a hazmat suit
and you have to wear a mask underneath
and then if i reach in to pull it down
to take a sip
what if you put the cloth mask like over
the plastic
that's an interesting point because
you'd be like i'm wearing the mask well
it's like apparently this plastic that
like doesn't really do anything so dude
it's about obedience exactly there was
there was a guy who wore pantyho he wore
panties on his face
which which is a cloth mask and they
kicked him off this is going well they
didn't see this article yet he's the one
who wrote it not pantyhose
this is good
women's underwear i want to make a crude
oil
sheamus get ready cover your ears
i'm going to make a crude i'm going to
make a cream reference
you know make sure your ears are saying
say ian there's a lady president i said
did i call you ian
he's the one i'm used to saying things
that make me uncomfortable
oh yeah ian i love you you know
yeah they're gonna prepare the people
are you ready they're going to prepare
this is preparation for the us diplomats
that are going to be going into china
who are going to have to be tested in a
very specific way that i've been warning
about for many specific years which the
chinese government is bringing back
specifically for the olympics with their
butt swab covet test it's not even
swabbing it's butt insertion because it
uh it's
it's
literally it's just a medical procedure
so they don't swipe they just go in they
go in they don't swipe
how is that normal is that better than
the nose i don't get it
people are doing it that's what's
happening in china yeah because they
can't use their hands to resist they
just hold them down the u.s state
department had to send an official
notice to china saying stop doing this
to our diplomats
yes
i wonder if now they're bringing it back
for the olympics i wonder if fauci and
bill gates are just like
taking big bong rips in in the back room
laughing and and bill's like you should
tell them to put pantyhose on next in
fact
then we'll tell them to wear two
pantyhose dudes
they're literally beavers and butthead
right
hey bill i like that cartoon that's a
cartoon we should do it hey bill
that would [ __ ] that would be cool
yeah
what make them wear uh
what's next that's the question what
what are they going to make you do next
here's the thing you use it's like gotta
start toilets right gloves because
infections are going they never did
gloves
well i think because cases are going
down and they're desperate to search for
other stories the covet stuff might
start to fizzle out and they're just
going to try to replace it with a new
story at the cove i mean the actual
virus is mutating and now we've got
delta strain or we've got
now where you've been eating we've got
them all now
which is less deadly so i think that the
whole pandemic thing is seems to be
quieting down and it just feels like it
the last couple weeks well the cases are
going down dramatically uh in canada in
the united states and there's trends
that uh you know people countries like
south africa are following and we're
following those trends very closely
and that leaves a lot of room for
optimism and there's also going to be a
lot of people wanting some significant
um
how do you say this um accountability
revenge
i was going to say retribution but i
didn't want to go there um but there's
going to be a lot of people who are
going to want to hold the government
officials that lock them up accountable
for
their uh crimes against them you know
yeah yeah i mean people are going to be
very upset people are going to be very
upset about it but that's why the media
is going gonna do everything they can to
just try to talk about something else of
course they're not gonna go like well
you know cases are down things are okay
you can go back to normal life they're
literally just gonna stop talking well
they're gonna need to shock the general
public with something dramatic to get us
away from paying attention to the
reality of the larger circumstances that
are going to be unfolding within the
next few weeks you think they'll uh do a
false flag in ukraine i've been uh well
this is what the u.s state department is
saying that russia is going to do
um very very uh there was a press
conference by the state department they
were questioned by a journalist
specifically asked about this because
the state department came and said that
they were going to do a false flag and
adjourn the journalists was like this is
like alex jones stuff that you're
talking about and the state department
couldn't answer the question of any kind
of legitimate evidence presented
accusing russia are they going to do a
false false flag where they have an
american do some crime and they're like
that was a russian dressed us in america
my goodness
so many levels possibly there's many
different possibilities here but wars
are started under many times
historically through false flag
operations
historically you know because you can't
just
preemptively attack someone um and just
say we we just needed to do so you need
an excuse for the general public to go
along with it you need an excuse to
build up the morale of this of the
soldiers uh to get them to go out there
and to commit some of the most heinous
atrocities against other human beings
you need a motivation factor um so
there's a big possibility of this what's
that cass's belly it's a cause for an
actor situation provoking or justifying
war yeah
so there's like there's got to be
something for a claim like your
great-great-grandfather owned that land
and now you have a right to it could be
that typically no it could be it's got
to be a grievance yeah so it's like it's
it's really funny too because often in
justifying a war it's to like convince
other people that you know you're on the
right side or whatever so they side with
you otherwise it would just be like i'm
gonna win the war and declare it so i'll
you know whatever that's how it used to
be it's like we know we're gonna win so
we go to war now with the international
stage it's like okay we'll go to war but
we need to make sure everyone thinks we
are the good guys that's why you first
needed information war before you
actually have a hot war you need the
build up you need the the the pr you
need all
you need to convince people because when
it comes to war when it comes to killing
another fellow human being you really
have to sell this idea uh as a life and
death situation and what better way than
to false flag an event to start this
because no one wants war
the bankers the the corporate heads the
billionaires they want wars and they
will stop nothing at getting it if
country leaders got together like biden
putin she all these leaders that they
could do something that would be more
powerful than global banking
um i i don't know about that um i i
think you know i was i was thinking you
were going to say they were all going to
be dosed by dmt yeah that was first
and then maybe there's a potential for
understanding this that's i thought i
thought you were going there for sure uh
but that's a very hypothetical question
that i don't have the answers to
i wish i did i wonder where the power
lies i usually think it lies in the
military but like you're saying
information and economics
someone's super chatted gulf of honkin
slam dunk that is pretty that's a good
start the gulf of tonkin is an excellent
example for anybody who doesn't believe
in false flags they tell you you're
crazy and alex jones be like we're
talking about gulf of tonkin it's on
wikipedia yeah like the america
americans claimed they got attacked but
even by entering a war even germany's
invasion of poland there was an attack
on a radio station that was questioned
as there was prisoners that were dressed
up in german uniforms and polish
uniforms there was allegedly a skirmish
where poland attacked germany first
operations north woods
there's so many instances even you know
the sinking of the there's questions
about the lusitania the spanish-american
war uh there's there's so many of these
incidences that of course it's it's it's
more common than uncommon and we should
always be wary of them especially with
such a tense situation unfolding right
now between the united states and russia
with the military-industrial complex and
the corporate media pushing everything
towards a direction that's going to mean
some kind of war in ukraine which is
going to be they need estrus they need
it i want to i want to make two very
important points absolutely super chats
the the the democratic establishment is
in such dire straits they need a
conflict war usually does really well
for leaders i don't know if it'll work
this time around because we got the
internet but the other thing you need to
understand is
joe biden should already be campaigning
and fundraising donald trump already is
now not full scale
but the fact that there's not even any
kind of hints of re-election work on joe
biden's part leads me to believe there's
there's we're starting to see the
beginning of evidence he's not going to
be running for 2024. if it's true he's
saying he's gonna right but come on look
at the guy if it's true that biden is
not running we would probably know
within the next four months
because the democrats need to get people
fundraising for primary season and
normally with an incumbent president
they'd be gearing up saying support us
but joe biden is not doing it yet we'll
see just so you know though
we should know very very soon biden's
inviting russia to to invade ukraine
with his statements and comments on that
situation which which is only getting
more tense with the united states
shipping and more weapons sending in
more troops it's it's crazy all right
let's read some super chats if you
haven't already if you haven't already
smash the like button one like is one
hunk
support the show surprise subscribe to
this channel and become a member at
timcast.com we're gonna have that
members only segment coming up around 11
or so pm and as a member you are helping
us do this show you're helping keep all
of our journalists employed you're
helping us expand and do more in the
face of all of the lies the
manipulations let me just let me just
mention that you guys supporting this
show has directly contributed to the the
cultural shift that sees cnn on the outs
with abysmal ratings our show doing
better than ever so thank you all so
much seriously let's read these super
chats we got simon who says please
support convoy 2022 new zealand to stop
the new zealand mandates two convoys of
trucks leaving the north and south
island of nz and meeting in the middle
at the capitol wellington on monday
nzst sunday est very very interesting
cyclops says the new jordan peterson
album truth and dragons by akira the
dawn drops tonight come join us on the
on the premiere leads can vouch for
akira and meaning wave he's wonderful
very important super chat here from the
the pippin viking hong kong
oh yes very very important i got you
buddy
all right carl andre says luke i heard a
tale you were barred from tim cast until
you could lift your rv from a mar-a-lago
swamp with alex jones sitting atop it
welcome back
it was pretty heavy but uh we are
already able to get it done
jordan says honkity honkers
huh all right christina h says hong kong
luke is my hero and lydia is my spirit
animal i love you all
well there we go nice what kind of
animal are you linda uh i think we came
up with i'm like an otter or something i
don't remember
silly
andre says breaking ontario needs to
reassess the value of covet 19 passport
system top doctor says
could it be that the truckers
are winning
perhaps
isaac says i feel like money being given
to blm was some sort of ransom
it sounds like a we'll ride and burn the
town down unless you pay us sort of
thing yep
but they still did that
they still did it maybe they stopped and
they started getting some of that money
though
all right we got money filthy pete says
i hate to be the energy killer but i
believe the trucker convoy is another
government planned psyop probably the
escape probably to scapegoat the
truckers and blame them for the massive
supply shortages we are about to see
maybe
but i think we already had supply
shortages before the trucker convoy
anyway so you know maybe maybe and plus
the government is implementing a policy
that will only exacerbate the global
supply chain problem even that much
worse they're responding and protesting
a policy that would open up the global
supply chain i actually did a video
about this because there are elements of
this especially allegedly elon musk
supporting the truckers especially with
him trying to bring autonomous trucks
especially with him uh you know
being a billionaire that leads to a lot
of very serious questions especially
with the possibility of global supply
chains being interrupted even more yeah
if you had as autonomous trucks and you
controlled the fleet you could just
block traffic at will yeah so but i
think by and large the movement is a net
positive and
sheamus looks defeated right now i
looked someone they pointed they're
right that would have been a good joke
so there's a super it happens every now
and again there's a super chat from
james nelson
uh sheamus put out a video a cartoon on
freedom tunes where trudeau is just
don't spoil the whole thing you guys
should check it out that if you read but
read the comments tim what happened just
tell me
it's just it's what i was going to say
once you watch it luke it's a minute
okay it's true and truckers totally
short it's true doe and he's trying to
talk truckers
james ellison says sheamus you missed a
huge joke when the trucks fly by the
diesel smoke should have left a
blackface residue on justin
well james i actually find that very
offensive
[Laughter]
i thought of that joke but i said i'm
gonna be bigger you missed
you know what it's it's it's a good bit
i'll admit it every now and again this
happens delete the video re-upload it
you know your accomplishment's gonna be
going to work
yeah you make a cartoon a week sometimes
two have a great team helping you but
every now and again sometimes something
slips through the cracks but i
appreciate that uh i'm kind of kicking
myself out i'll just make four or five
minutes i just gotta make a couple more
look there will be plenty of of uh i had
trudeau do green face in another video
you guys can check that out yeah joe
biden meets aliens
germanic bear says since luke is
basically the guest can you tell us more
about his family from poland he alludes
he alludes to it very often it sounds
like they are fascinating people worth
talking about absolutely my father has
an incredible story my mother is a solid
rock uh hardcore polish mom that has all
the basic stereotypes and you know my
grandparents uh have even crazier
stories especially when it comes
uh with it comes
to surviving world war ii communism the
soviet union there's there's such crazy
insane stories of survival i am
extremely lucky to be alive i am
extremely lucky to be here since
my you know bloodline my family before
me came very close to losing it all on
many occasions because of big
governments totalitarianism communism
and fascism and my people have always
been pushing against centralization for
a very long time historically poland has
existed and hasn't existed my family's
history has been wiped out before world
war ii because
of uh you know what what the soviet
union and what what germany did
essentially exterminating a lot of not
only my family members but a lot of our
history that has stopped there sadly so
i only know up until then and eve even
up till then it's absolutely crazy and
mind-boggling to hear the stories of my
grandmother talking about how she was
literally on a train to shoot off
concentration camps and was luckily
saved and like how the russians came in
and screwed everyone and enslaved
everyone and started torturing people my
uncle who was literally tortured by the
the gestapo police officers and the deep
state cops that were in poland at the
time so there's such an incredible
history i should probably do a video
about this just going over my my like
lineage of family members that are
absolutely hardcore anti-statist
uh
my grandma being the most hardcore
anti-statist of them all you know we
need we need an anime origin story for
luke and it'll be like you know young
seven-year-old luke and his dad's like
smoking a cigarette and he's like
luke
you must always resist it's got another
it's gotta be like luke's like awesome
family going through all these insane
things but then like somehow they end up
with yeah it should start off with luke
famous
that's a low blow
with luke firing the rocket launcher and
then the explosion of the smoke appears
like his childhood is like him as a kid
with his dad talking well i'm nothing
compared to like what my father went
through uh he was a part of the you know
solidarity movement he was he was a
major uh component of the movement to
bring freedom into poland and to fight
communism uh you know my grandmother
again also a big proponent fighting
communism faced being sent to jail on
many occasions
we had our house raided uh by the police
you know
there's so many crazy stories it's
mind-boggling luke is third generation
anti-communist yep were they all out of
the soviet union when it fell by the
time it fell uh-huh
your family were they still living there
well some of them some of them died some
of them got you know of course taken out
but i don't hold the candle to anything
my my family and my my forbearers went
through before me i have it extremely
lucky uh i'm extremely privileged
comparatively to what they had to go
through i mean they were they were
essentially even starved in some
instances
because of the lack of food under
communism and uh we are incredibly lucky
extremely privileged and we should
always remember that every single day
and i always remember my family what
what they went through when it comes to
my my job and my reporting
all right we got it beautiful alex says
so is crenshaw going to reschedule yes
uh they just had a vote there he has
yeah yeah these are scheduled um
and we are also can we can we mention
the margery taylor green thing is that i
won't say the exact date but yeah yeah
uh so marjorie taylor green and thomas
massey right yep i believe so we won't
take the exact date because then when
they cancel
like
inevitable well i mean especially with
people who are in congress because of
what may come up but we're uh we're
planning on having margery taylor green
and thomas massion at the same time to
talk about what's going on in congress
but thank thank thank god thank the
lucky stars luke is leaving
before that i would have loved to talk
to credshaw i mean i flew here just to
talk to him well i thought i would have
been an incredible conference i don't
wanna i don't wanna make it seem like
you flew here just for that before luke
left
we had we had discussed with uh dan
crenshaw coming on the show and so i
told luke hey like you know don't leave
yet dan's gonna come on the show but
look was like we've already scheduled it
and i was like well make sure you come
back you know around then so there was
always the plan to have luke on the show
when dan came you know because what what
i don't want to do is make it seem like
we're going to bring people on because
someone's coming i want to give
everybody a fair shake at having their
chance to come here and speak their mind
especially dan because a lot of people
are are critical of him you know
absolutely and it would have been an
incredible conversation that could have
gone either ways but i think it would
have been positive for everyone involved
you just got to stay until next week
just to stay until next week i don't i
don't smell that bad
you can stick around for a week i don't
know it smells like potatoes and whiskey
that is so first of all that sounds
amazing
all right well aside from crenshaw
daniel says
jordan peterson is stateside again and
he plans to have him on is he still in
the in the us
yes i am yeah i don't know i think so
we'll just have you you should bring him
on you bring jordan on i'd love to i hit
him up a couple weeks ago but i don't
think he's i don't know if you saw my
tweet or anything jordan or michaela i
know mikayla does a lot of his booking i
would love to give jordan in here while
he's around oh man would be cool right
yeah
raymond g stanley jr says omg is that
luke rodkowski on the show how did you
manage that he's so dreamy whoa luke if
there was to be change who would be or
is that change
uh you and uh decentral and the ideas
and principles of decentralization and
taking responsibility for yourself and
not depending on anyone else not giving
up your power as a human being to anyone
else and understanding that your life
has value you have power dignity respect
and and the most amazing thing in your
existence the ability to critically
think analyze information and then make
the right decisions for yourself as an
individual that right there is some of
the
best things that i have the most
absolute hope in the individual deciding
what's right for themselves
did you feel like obama ripped you off
when he did the absolute can movement
absolutely three syllables and then
people conflated people thought we were
related to barack obama when we had we
are changed way before he did it
and and and it was it was frustrating
for a bit because everyone everyone
when i met you i was like this guy's
related to obama yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah you have great perception
famous
they probably ripped you off all right
awm fishing and gaming says i just post
my college degree when someone belittles
someone for being uneducated because
they didn't follow the state propaganda
yep i know some people that will remain
unnamed they're just they're just like
well i'm in mensa it's like oh
congratulations you solved puzzles so so
you're very smart you're paying people
money to tell you how smart you are yeah
how smart is that that's pretty smart
it's almost embarrassing i'll i'll tell
you this if um here's what we'll do we
uh uh members of uh tip guests are all
really smart you have to be smart and so
only the smart people are allowed to do
members of tim cast that's right and
we'll send you an email that says you're
very smart forgiveness
you're very smart
when you talk about smart is it like
intelligence and emotions are both like
50 50 part of being smart because i i
have an issue with that word smart it's
a kind of vague i wonder if it's like a
combination intelligence like we were
saying earlier you can be intelligent
and do horribly dumb things
well there's different kinds of
intelligence
you you know that's why
different people learn different ways
some people could have really good
memories but really bad comprehension
but let's read some more
all right the bros durham says you guys
always forget the most important trade
the machinist
oh yes the machinist
machinists are very important indeed
they are
kit m says everybody is a genius but if
you judge a fish by its ability to climb
a tree it will live its whole life
believing that it is stupid well fish
are stupid that is
unless you need someone to find bugs for
once they are noble yeah there's a video
going viral on reddit of uh i think it's
like a hawk attacking
i saw that one and then the roaster runs
out and attacks it and goes nuts heroic
yeah roosters will they create they
sacrifice their lives to save them
like roosters are not like very nice to
the hens but they will stand up for them
it's kind of crazy because roosters in
many ways are like
more likely to be a better man than a
human
you know like there are a lot of guys
that will like run away and leave their
girl in danger but roosters won't nope
they'll be like i will fight that bear
and then they'll just give them all
[Laughter]
toxic rooster masculinity man by the way
i did not mean to make fun of that super
chatter there's an interesting thing
about that quote however i would
disagree with the idea that everyone's a
genius because then then then the word
loses meaning i think it's einstein i'm
pretty sure that's an einstein well
maybe he wasn't he was made to feel
stupid in school uh
it's a famous quote no no no i've heard
it i get what they're saying but i
wouldn't say everybody's a genius all
right grizzlab says hey tim a canadian
trucker here i can explain trucking
industry and what trudeau did to our
economy on your show if you allow me
well it's always difficult to bring
people from canada but uh you can always
send a shout out to what spin the ufo
gmail.com that's right you will check
those yep
and uh we will we will we will talk
i think it would actually be really
great we've had a bunch of
recommendations for truckers and people
involved and that's something
yeah we should we should try and figure
that that'd be cool actually
thomas sidebottom says sheamus some
churches are on metaverse i'm curious
what you think of this given your views
on how church affects sense of community
some are even performing baptisms in
virtual water do you consider these
baptisms legitimate no i don't i don't
consider those to be legitimate baptisms
i'm no theologian but i understand so i
know at the very least like with with
confession for example if you want to be
absolved you have to be like in person
with the priest you can't do that
virtually i think it's good for people
to build a faith community over the
internet i think it's really great to
stay in contact with like-minded people
especially if there aren't folks around
you who share your values but i i don't
believe that sacraments could be
administered digitally
i can i can double check on that but i'm
i'm pretty sure again no theologian here
but
shiloh crew says do you remember when
blm insisted that it's okay to destroy
jesus statues and portraits because
jesus was black how does that line up
with whoopi's belief that nazi germany
was whites versus whites you remember
that
when they were when black was matter was
desecrating religious symbols yes and
they tried claiming all these people
were different races or whatever the
funny thing about is that everybody
knows jesus was japanese of course yeah
there's actually
but uh
you uh you probably know this you can
find depictions of jesus among all many
cultures well and that's actually very
important the catholic church and
i would say christianity in general in
general but i would say particularly the
catholic church because that's true the
tradition i'm most familiar with has
always been completely fine and even
encouraging of people depicting christ
to look as if they are part of the same
ethnic group that that person is because
christ is the visible face of the
invisible father
and to put so much emphasis on his
ethnicity that you would say you can't
envision him as looking as if he's from
the same group you are is ridiculous so
progressive i've heard theory it is like
you know it's diversity or whatever but
they don't like it
the theories that jesus is like an idea
uh from like the sun god from from egypt
i've heard the wild theory is that it's
more of um just this caricature that
people have like bestowed up you guys
i've heard that but yeah that's all the
egyptology stuff is like really they'll
say things like oh he's based on the sun
god that's why we call him the son of
god but in the ancient egyptian language
the word for like the sun is not the
same as the word for
uh the male child so like it's it's
really based on it's it's based on
english puns it's really not a
legitimate theory but you guys should
have a long conversation i think ian i
think we should actually i would be very
interested i feel like i wouldn't be
able to bring enough to the convo but if
i trust you if you think we could do it
it would be entertaining i'm 100
otherwise a third person that's like a
expert in something what works is you'll
be the hippie dmt guy just asking much
about you just play devil's advocate
honestly that's another fun thing too
just like poke and proud me it's
difficult it's difficult
sometimes i know you're gonna make some
you sick man but yeah i know i mean like
like just i think that would be
interesting we just sit down you ask
questions challenge my arguments i'd
enjoy that so this is the funny thing
about when i see
these like liberal types on facebook
posting pictures of a middle eastern
jesus and they're like hey christians
this is what jesus looked like and i'm
like i don't think they've ever actually
a single christian christian person yeah
yeah and and if you so that what i
always do is i you google search and
there's japanese portraits of a japanese
jesus and so i copy that and just paste
and say you're wrong jesus is japanese
and i do that basically because of what
you said that different cultures depict
them as you know their ethnicity but
these people don't know anything about
the the belief but let's let's read some
more super chats all right the sinister
sibling says in terms of conspiracies
here's one i think the d-glock a world
war ii german attempt at an anti-gravity
craft that according to scientists
disappeared in front of them is the
reason for the ufo sightings so it's not
aliens but an out-of-control german time
machine oh okay that sounds like a great
movie idea how do you spell that i will
fund that movie
how did you spell d grock that thing you
were d glock d-glock d-e-g-l-e-i-e
g-l-o-c-k-e thank you the germans were
working on some pretty crazy stuff yeah
there wasn't any surprise that there was
some elements of that to be verifiable
there was a funny the bell okay this is
oh yeah is the bell i've heard of this
this this floating bell thing maybe it's
spinning super fast so it reduces
vertical lag i guess you could call it
and it can float sort of if it's
spinning fast enough i think that's the
idea if you hit it with electrical
current and it's spinning super fast
corey g says tim got it right the
average person is basically a child
people stopped growing up because good
times make soft men yep
you know and it really is true
uh
i think you look at we'll use luke as a
really good example
luke's family history made one heck of a
hard man
strong man that's probably the right way
to put it right luke i i still don't
hold a candle to what my family went
through no but i mean like you know
especially your dad right oh yeah he
went through all this hardship you grew
up seeing that
and you know you you guys fled you were
born into a soviet satellite state your
family flees you come to the united
states so you knew what that hardship
was and that seed planted in you allows
you to grow up and do the work you're
doing now and appreciate what
opportunities we have here in this
country which of course we didn't have
and still in some elements don't have in
poland even though poland's doing really
well right now comparatively to the rest
of europe but still comparatively in
america we are extremely privileged
extremely lucky and any opportunity you
have you have to take especially when
you look at it from an international
perspective understanding how the world
really is
all right dr marcelo santo says
brazilian here bolsonaro is freedom
loving fighting against socialism and
narco traffic in brazil and south
america google el pollo
the chicken
el pollo loco remember when bolsonaro
got they tried to kill him they knifed
him in the gut no yeah oh yeah was that
recent no it was just years ago he was
there he was at a rally and they were
holding him up and some guys plunged a
knife into them
that's crazy man
they were like yeah she asked me
people are crazy that's what he screamed
yes waffle sensei says luke broke the
science
yeah he did i did he was asking for it
machisma joe mcismojo says we need the
50 bmg because we have to push for
autonomous cars and trucks that could
one day decide to initiate carmageddon
it's that simple when the robots take
over a shotgun won't stop them
yeah i saw that article that said
optimus prime was not at the
at the convoy oh yeah
his silence his silence has been
deafening that's right that's true
okay
i don't know if i can read this person's
name but uh cooter says johnny that's
not the full name johnny knoxville has
had a cannon since jackass too
man joe biden he's just got to watch
jackass yeah you know you can go you can
go online just buy cannons there's a new
jackass coming out all right immortal
sinban says tim would love your feedback
and anyone else who wants to check it
out uh of our heavy metal cover of will
of the people it's the newest lyric
video on our immortal sin band channel
also on spotify apple amazon deezer
etcetera oh really really cool i i i
appreciate and encourage people to cover
the song and so cool that'd be really
awesome
you looked at that video game oh yeah
yeah i didn't fall through remind me
after the show cause i want to take a
look at that and we'll take a look at uh
your heavy metal cover and then if you
go to my instagram
one of the posts it shows like a
computer screen we're working on what is
essentially a sequel to will of the
people it's like not really a sequel but
it's in the same universe the song is
based and it's called pain and we've got
pete pirata formerly of the offspring
who's done the drums for it we've got a
rough mix so far and it just sounds so
good i'm so excited yo pete you rock
yeah it's so good and and pete posted a
video on his instagram of how he did the
drums and it's like three different drum
tracks he's playing the drums in
different ways at the same time is that
pain for pain yeah
yeah
and
carter sent me the latest mix
and i'm just like the song's good enough
it doesn't need vocals or anything else
it's just good enough already but but
someone told me it sounds like a song
from like a tony hawk pro skater game
yeah they're like it sounds like you
know tony hawk pro skater music and i'm
like all right cool
all right tina collette says i live in
wyoming we lived in a community a few
years ago that had a cannon they would
fire it a couple times a year i can
guarantee there are several times the
number of guns to the population and no
gun crime the funny thing is
most of the weapons from back then
aren't regulated firearms you can you
can like they're
you have to muzzle load them they're not
banned they never were they're not now
so joe biden coming out and being like
you're gonna have a cannon it's like you
can you could you still can you probably
always can because it's archaic
technology but people had warships back
then i'm tired of the lies dude that's
why i'm saying like the second amendment
guarantees my right to own nuclear
nuclear warheads so here's the question
tim do you think i mean some of them i'm
sure are lying but
do you think they're
lying in mass or do you think a lot of
them just don't know anything and they
assume pc's well it sounds right to say
that you can't own a candidate so i'll
just say it even though i've never
looked into it
yeah it just sounds right yeah you can
own a cannon yes i can you can own a
tank yes you can yeah there's there's
websites where you can buy tanks
vice did i think buzzfeed did it invited
an article on it where they were like
here's a guy who bought a tank and like
drives it around we there we saw i saw a
a guy in west virginia who had a a jeep
mounted 50 bmg
on it like you're you can have these
things
it's like it's not easy they're making
it harder and harder and harder
especially with the nfa but you can have
these things canon's a weird one because
it's useless relatively you can't
conceal it they can't they're hard to
aim i mean they were good when you were
finding boats that move really slow
you're going to think a cannon's useless
until someone points one at you yeah i
am a good point
citizens
are we should we legally be allowed to
have nuclear bombs i don't know that's
we should i don't think we can have that
conversation in five minutes civilians
should be able to own anything a soldier
can own
yep that's good rule of thumb
all right soldiers have can on those
either only a president has access to
that stuff
joshua thomas says as a diesel mechanic
for a trucking company that does a lot
of grocery shipping i am ecstatic for
some of these truckers also being in las
vegas i don't know how many people know
that this city would not exist without
them
vegas is being terraformed you know this
so what's happening is this is an
amazing story last time i was in vegas i
noticed there were a lot more clouds
than so i i went to vegas in like 2012
and then it came like five years later
and i was like it's kind of like a lot
of clouds up there and i asked people it
wasn't super cloudy if there was just
some clouds and they were they said what
happens is
people will get on planes
they'll fly to vegas
and they will do their dirty business
the planes will unload all of that waste
in las vegas airport which goes into the
sewer systems out there which brings
moisture and water into vegas which then
evaporates goes into the atmosphere
isn't that crazy that is pretty crazy
and then they also when they ship in
water and drinks people drink it there
use the bathroom there they're
effectively moving massive amounts of
water into the desert and making the air
bring moisture in which is and they're
also making lawns for people's houses
which then retain moisture so they're
basically turned they're de-deserting
vegas it's crazy china's doing that too
but they're doing it like more
methodically you know
all right let's grab just like one more
super chat
david munoz says my theory on great
pyramid construction sound waves were
used to capture a block and move it in
place with relative ease we were able to
do it now with small objects sound waves
create a bubble
i got bad news for the ancient aliens
people and for theories like that
it's actually not complicated to have
built the pyramid in fact the pyramid is
one of the easiest structures to build
when you have limited technology because
it's literally just stacking the blocks
up
i think the basic understanding is that
all they did was they literally just
pushed blocks across thin layers of sand
which creates you know reduces the
friction and then they they had people
move them up at the center of it and
slowly place them piece by piece in
water yeah
i've also heard that they poured water
in front of them and that would be
easier for them to slide across the sand
yeah and then they would float the
blocks in water and they you'd be able
to spin the block yeah along the outside
of the pyramid this is one thing i've
seen is that there's a corridor of water
that went up around the outside of the
pyramid and so they would literally and
then they would uh there's a word for
what these things are you shut it off at
one point so the water can't go any
further back down and then the valve you
get the block up now there's the
specific word
and it moves upwards and then they can
spin the block around and carve it on
all four sides and then they'd be
covered so from the sun and they would
keep them cool being in the water and
working in the water all day yeah so
there's there's a dude who uh talks
about like the ancient mayan structures
and stuff and he was like it's actually
really easy to move multi-ton blocks and
he was like all you do is you dig a hole
on one side of it and then it it flips
over and moves it's like it's actually
really simple but who gave them the
shovels tim
oh you're right aliens that's right no
you see what it was was that one day
humans had never dug a hole in their
lives until one man they called him
prometheon saw bill dog bill holt saw a
person a dog
using his paw uh you know and he was
like he looked at his hands he went
and then he stuck his hand in the dirt
and moved the dirt he saw a dog digging
in front of a large block of wood that
then came and crushed the dog
all right everybody if you haven't
already smash that like button one like
equals one honk shout out to the
truckers in canada and all those working
so hard and standing up for their rights
with the great honking go to timcast.com
become a member check out our store get
your free hunk hunk t-shirt and it's not
a free shirt it's not free it's free
hong kong can you buy this shirt but
become a member we're gonna have a
members only segment coming up for you
around 11 or so p.m subscribe as i
mentioned you can follow us at tim cast
irl basically everywhere we're on
instagram with clips from the show so
follow us there follow me at tim cast
luke shout out your shirts honk uh my
youtube channel is youtube.com forward
slash we are change i did a video today
about how desperate the state is
becoming i also do videos on
lukencensor.com i'm going to be doing in
life meetups in fort lauderdale probably
next friday
to find out about that sign up on my
email list we are change.org and uh
sheamus
even though it's uh really fun to easily
poke at your uh readily available
buttons
i i think you do a great job and i think
you are are not that bad that was the
best joke so far
do you ever notice it's tim pitting us
against each other i know it's a
conspiracy he's the bill gates we're the
peasants here and we're being easily
manipulated and played here
but in all seriousness you do a great
job and i'm appreciative likewise much
appreciated man this is what the
establishment fears
that's what tim fears that's what tim
fears oh
but no i mean i i feel the same way
we're you know we poke fun at each other
we're mutual fans luke has sort of left
the show and i've been keeping a seat
warm doing the show and there are
sometimes fans are like oh we miss luke
or sometimes fans are like oh we love
sheamus
i think it's i i think it should be
known that we really are fans of one
another it was it was actually funny the
day like the last day luke was here
right when he walked out right out of
the door in the show and then we're like
all right see you later luke as soon as
he did all of a sudden i turn around and
sheamus is literally an inch from my
face and he's like hey tim can i be on
the show no no no no no i was in luke's
chair with my feet
that's right
but no um so thank you very much for
that and again it's mutual and um if you
guys would like to check out my work i
create political cartoons and animations
at a channel called freedom tunes we
release every single thursday which
means we released one this morning it's
doing pretty well it's one of our most
popular videos in a while it's about
trudeau and the trucks i have a feeling
that you guys will enjoy it so go over
there and check that out and if you want
to help us make more of them like share
subscribe leave a comment and if you're
feeling crazy donate at patreon.com
freedom tunes and thank you so much for
your time tonight i had a
an awesome time on the show yeah yeah
i'm glad that uh we were able to get
some of these ideas out there it was
really fun it's fun watching you guys go
at it i like sitting on the cross the
table from you i noticed in the old
studio me and tim said across from each
other and it was real adversarial we'd
constantly going at it because like when
you're directly across from someone
that's just that's it energy
hey follow me ian crossland.net i love
you guys thanks for coming see you later
you guys freedom isn't free and neither
is the free hong kong t-shirt but it is
a good investment and i really recommend
you guys go over to the site and get
your own today we have red and black
they're both awesome i really want one
myself i might try to get one to wear on
fridays we'll see what happens with that
you guys can follow me on twitter and
minds at sourpatchlids there are free
honk honk stickers as well you can get
you can you know slap them on things and
spread the message so go to timcast.com
become a member and we will see you all
there around 11 or so p.m thanks for
hanging out bye guys
you